all right
guys welcome welcome today's live show
all right i don't know why
[Music]
i don't know why man every time the law
order thing comes on that [ __ ] slaps
but maybe this is not appropriate i feel
like this is having for his channel so i
should give you guys what you actually
came for
god damn mission slaps now we're not
going to do that we don't get straight
to the point today
glad you guys can make it glad you guys
can make it for today's live i'm doing
these impromptu lives with some
different ideas
just to have a little bit of fun um i
like a lot of smaller channels i like
the idea of people starting youtube
channels trying to make it work but
sometimes
uh you know people who run small
channels make a lot of minor mistakes
that i think kind of hampers them from
getting to bigger places so this is not
a referendum on people's opinions
this is not a referendum on the
direction
in terms of like political commentary
that channels want to make all i'm going
to look at
is one a couple of criterias so
sound quality video quality uh is your
[ __ ] concise
or is your editing on point uh do you
have any good intangibles that makes
your channel set apart
and then i'm probably gonna look like
upload schedule do you have a focus with
your content
are you just kind of open and still
figuring it out i'm going to try to make
this
as concise and as effective as possible
so that if any of them do watch this
they get some good information from this
and that's pretty much the gist of it i
like supporting small creators i used to
be one um
you know and um you know if any of our
advice can help great you know not
everyone has to take the same trajectory
to get there
uh but you know i like supporting folks
so this will be a good way if you guys
like any of the channels that i
mentioned
go out show them some love even if i
disagree with what the person is saying
on the video please guys
do not go to say anything negative about
them i know you guys love us you want to
defend us but it's not necessary we're
grown men
and we can handle criticism or
disagreeing opinions okay
so
let's get this [ __ ] popping i'm going to
be choosing mostly channels
with 75 000 and below subscribers a lot
of them are gonna have
less than a thousand i picked out eight
videos that i haven't watched fully
except for one
uh and so that's his channel size i
think if you're a medium-sized channel
i don't think my advice applies as well
because you probably already figured out
a lot of things that are working i'm
really going for really tiny channels
uh for the most part so
um let's get the show popping
all right um so i'm going to go with
this
person first so
this is a channel called the apartments
uh departments like i guess uh
i guess all these guys live in the same
apartment building or something
um okay so let's just start right here
framing
i think because they're four people and
they want to have everybody in frame
they have to frame it this way i can
tell the quality the camera is not the
best but that's not the most important
thing
tip to anybody who's watching the most
important thing when you're making video
content online
is sound quality yes you could use a
[ __ ]
cell phone and nobody would give a [ __ ]
but if your sound is trash
people will turn off your bro i know big
channels okay
oh i know a big channel what the [ __ ]
his name i think his name is like uh
let me find him his name is swoozie
okay i don't know how this guy gets away
with it
okay the sound quality he's a huge
creator with 7.37 million subscribers
but the sound quality on this man's
videos
some of them listen to this [ __ ] bro so
for anybody who's not familiar with the
term simp
i heard somebody you hear that hissing
noise bro this [ __ ] sounds like that
like it's out of the blair witch project
it's so bad and it triggers me i can't
watch a full video even though i do
think his content is good but
put it in a really good way you have a
dog who loves his own pet owner get
somebody
poor cat online correct a little while
ago i had a girl hit me up and she was
like
the sound quality is so bad so bad
people still watch it because the
content's really strong
but i would probably tell you that the
visuals generally speaking
are less important than
um the the the
the [ __ ] it called the audio is
generally way more important than the
visuals
um so that would probably be my first
set of uh things i would tell you guys
so let me just go back to this over here
so yeah um i i don't mind the video
quality provided the sound quality is
going to be good i think this framing is
all right
um maybe they could use a bit of color
correction maybe add a bit of contrast
lower down the brightness just to make
it look less faded and less
white um they could probably
like you see how much space there is
right over their heads like
for framing for me that's like never
necessary you have so much space unless
you don't stand and be like hey what's
up
you want the frame to be concise like if
i go on any big youtube channels
like all right i'm gonna go i'm gonna
pick somebody uh
let me see who's trending let me see
what's trending is there a trending tab
no
how do you find the trending this is how
little i explore youtube bro
uh cell phone
review
okay this guy's a perfect example all
right i don't watch his content but i
watched a single video on time
and i kept thinking he does the framing
perfectly because there's still a market
for it
you see how the framing you see how
there's not too much space over the head
even
the large wide frame is to showcase all
the cell phones on purpose i'm sure if i
went to other videos like this one
he wouldn't do that 750 phone when
pretty much every other android so this
is how you do proper framing even notice
the way like the screens are set up and
all that
this is all extra it's not necessary if
you just have a good frame on you
that makes it look clean that's already
good enough so those are little things
you can do
uh to kind of maximize uh
certain things but anyways let me go
back to the video because i don't want
to spend too much time on this
specific point but let's uh let's just
watch a little bit
okay cool so what they did at the
beginning is that they put a little
preview of something funny
to get the viewer hooked in which is
actually a really good strategy
especially if you've got a high moment
that comes way later on well someone
who's stumbling upon your video in the
first
20 seconds they might be like yo what's
this boring [ __ ]
where's the good parts they're not gonna
click but if they see something that's
really good
right off the top that might hook them
into staying much longer
and tv shows have been doing this
forever i remember i saw this on someone
else's youtube channel and i just stole
it for myself so that's why you see
preach laughing at the beginning of
video
it lets the viewer know something good
is coming so that's a good little
thing that they did uh that i like
youtube
you know who it is you know where we at
it's live from the apartments you
already know who it is it's your boy jay
i'm here with man you already know it's
your boy zayrobs
it's your boy abba it's your boy will
it's your boy preach
it's about at some point yo let's just
wrap up this introduction you feel me
um especially for new viewers they're
not going to waste time to find out who
you are that's why
when i do my videos i go straight to the
topic today's topic
this this happen here we go i want to
spend as little time with the
introduction as possible
so that when a viewer comes on and he's
watching they already know what time it
is feel me
so instead of um spending all this time
going uh
how do you guys feel about this and how
do you feel about that just go right
into it
okay um and i know this is kind of like
a
inception moment where i'm reacting to
people reacting to us to react like
i know okay but i think reaction
channels have a good
i call this more of a commentary channel
than i do a reaction channel
but that's just me because yes we are
we're having a reaction but we're adding
commentary we're adding a lot of
important information
important that's maybe being
self-important but uh
i think poignant commentary that really
does transform the work you know if you
saw a newscast with a panel you wouldn't
call them a reaction show
but what they do is they see an incident
that happens and they'll have a panel
they'll discuss what they're watching
right
kind of that same idea um but anyways
and we're coming at y'all with some abba
and preach this is a abba and preach
video it's titled
all women are the same or are single or
single
reading it wrong yeah you definitely
want to work on your reading skills but
bruh i understand
you guys are four dudes stuck in an
apartment sometimes you don't have time
for books i saw a little bit of this
i thought this would be a good video the
world is huge
like i get there is like probably a
small percentage but
i'm gonna say judging by the setup that
they have the sound quality is actually
pretty good
very impressive um very impressive the
sound quality is actually a lot better
than what i would expect
i don't hear a bunch of hissing so i
think someone's doing some form of
editing where they're
taking it out because i don't see a
bunch of mics everywhere i'm assuming
they're using the cell phones on the
table
to catch the sound from each individual
so they got
this is really smart okay now if you
can't afford a mic right if you can't
afford a mic you can't afford a camera
you can use a bunch of cell phones
get a couple friends grab some cell
phones there's voice memo
apps on most cell phones you can just
record your voice you hold it right
beside you
i've seen big ass channels do this okay
and you'll get decent sound quality
after that you do a little bit of post
editing and you can get good sound
quality so if you can't afford to get a
bunch of stuff that could be a good
alternative
um and then yes they set up two mics to
catch everything on the left side on the
right side so what they did is really
really smart
he's sitting here telling people to
think like like if you think if you got
a girl and you're thinking
as soon as you go out the house oh she's
single
okay second thing i like okay and this
is specifically for reaction channel add
commentary all right
there's a lot of channels that i
personally feel like a little bit lazy
and they just play the whole video and
then they add laughs in between which
listen some people just want to sit
there and watch something with somebody
so i understand those reaction channels
but i think commentary like this is much
better because it gives you it gives
them the opportunity the viewer
to see more of your personality so i
think what they're doing here is really
good
um and it seems to be the case for most
of the video in fact our video barely
plays they're
they're spending most of the time
talking so that's really good
maybe or if they know somebody but
that's just that's just for it to be
racial
i don't know if like the do-rags are
part of
are part of like the whole setup it
seems like all these guys own a helmet
of salvation which i think is dope
um so you guys wear that i like how the
white guy's the only one not wearing it
like whoa what just happened look at
this
video quality difference that's crazy
okay if they got this set up and they
can just fix the frame
these guys are gucci these guys are
gucci
um so these guys are called the
apartments let me uh let me just
oh if i haven't already yeah
yeah okay cool yeah go down here leave
them a comment show them some love
i'm gonna just check on their channel
real quick
okay yep they seem to be uploading
pretty regularly which is consistency is
always good um
thumbnails do you okay yeah i see the
thumbnails i'm not mad at these
thumbnails
um just keep improving on those
all right yep using bigger names
definitely does help just because then
it creates traction from
that fan base so i'm not mad at that
yeah i mean overall i think these guys
are doing a lot of good things as
they're gonna get better
sharper funnier you know quicker with
their commentary they're definitely
gonna do good
uh so shout out to the apartments um i
think in terms of
how they're starting i'd probably give
them like eight out of ten
i'll probably give them an eight out of
ten uh and i think as they get better
that's only gonna grow so
keep it up keep it up let's go to the
next person
okay this is ezzell reacts this is a
channel with 1000 subscribers
oh let me check the chat i didn't i
didn't check in with you guys what's
going on chat
all right we got some donations in this
[ __ ] all right hey we got carmen king
do cam and kay uh carmen i already
picked like the nine channels i picked
them kind of at random
so appreciate it can you review me
please is he land i've already picked i
didn't want people to pay in
or to ask me for favors i'm doing this
kind of off the cuff
so i don't want to favorite you know
show any favoritism to anybody
richard garcia abba how's the sleep
apnea i'm about to have a sleep study
coming up my sleep apnea is super severe
so i got my machine
it's already set up beside my bed uh if
you feel like you got sleep apnea and
they confirm it get the machine
hey mr bit eight raw thank you for the
ten dollar donut like i said i'm not
i'm not i'm not i'm not accepting any
payments i don't want to
uh to do any of that so if you're if
you're donating i appreciate it but i'm
not
not taking any bribes today
all right here we go ezreal reacts steve
harvey can't stop pandering oh this was
a good video
okay so this seems uh are they a couple
we are looking what's going on everybody
i'm iselle and this is my wife
and welcome to our reaction channel
named
the evils react today we are looking at
okay all right i don't know if this is
like a radio show i don't know what's
going on here
um okay a couple things all right off
the top
the music at the beginning as they're
trying to talk is so distracting for me
um it's making it hard for me to listen
to hear what they're saying and it kind
of makes me tune out
an already like very kind of dull
introduction just get right into it
um generally i'm not i'm not a
fan of those kinds of introduction and i
think you want to avoid drop off so i
wouldn't recommend going through with
this format
uh steve harvey can't stop pandering
yeah the music's loud as [ __ ] bro okay
hold up let me just go check another
video make sure i'm not tripping
okay let me just click on a random video
okay i'll just click on the most recent
one
see if they improve the setup
is my internet bugging what's going on
bro
what's going on guys my name is iselle
and this is my wife
elsa and welcome to our reaction channel
the easels
sorry guys i'm a little a little tired
um but you know what
okay this is much better okay this is
much much better
um sound quality is much better the
visual quality is a lot better
i like this setup a whole lot better i
think it i think the issue with this
video is because i think one of them
didn't have a headphones or something's
wrong
but this sounds way better so i'm going
to just go with this right that's why we
got to get it
cropped today and what i mean by oh okay
i just dated myself
i just dated myself i just said croc um
hey i'm i i really won't be laughing i'm
not gonna laugh
that one was kind of hard that one was
kind of hard
oh are they trying not to laugh stop
playing with me because of
their reaction and how the woman just
was like
i see tears in your eyes i don't yes i
do no
you don't right there oh people really
watch this video trying not to laugh
guys it's okay
just lose bring some happiness into your
life
look at his face
this man is really trying not to laugh
hey man just give up
i was not ready is this man crying
bro the try not to laugh challenge also
includes crying stop playing with me
again
okay
i think it's because uh
all right well looks like they made it
it was one point in the middle where i
try
so hard not to laugh good for them good
for them
um okay so get back to the topic of this
whole life
um visuals i like it audio i like it i
think their commentary in their back and
forth is good as they get better as they
get more free-flowing
uh and i think as they get more uh
opinions that they want inserted
obviously this is a compilation
i think they're gonna get better i think
it's just a matter of consistency and
attaching your name to
some interesting topics and then having
something interesting to say
um you know compilation video is a
little bit
tough to judge but in terms of like the
basics
[Music]
good i think they're doing a good job in
that regards yeah
yeah yeah yeah um i don't think these
thumbnails are very good
there's too much text generally for me
thumbnails should be simple you want
thumbnails to just
pow pop and then also not have too much
text on them or else it becomes too much
to look at
and your eyes like generally the best
thumbnails are simple ones
those are the ones that grip people so i
think their thumbnail game is not that
great
uh neither is their titling i think
titling is all right but in terms of
clickability
this is too much there's too much going
on
so i think that's probably would be one
of their weakest points
um yeah that'd probably be the advice
i'd give them
yeah that'd probably be the advice i'd
give them
yeah i think it's great that he's doing
with his wife it's kind of a cool thing
cool dynamic
um you know as a married couple maybe
just talking about your experience
you know mixing in a matter of like
reacting and also talking about stuff
that you guys find this poignant might
be a good mix
um yes that's about it for
this channel oh well this one
in terms of yeah yeah this one's good
all right let's go to the next one all
right so this one
is a channel i'd seen before
oh let me come back to the chat real
quick chad what'd you guys think am i
being fair
am i being fair to to to the people
yeah i feel like um i always want to to
help folks
zoom boy off topic question how
comfortable has your chair been thinking
about getting one
this chair is pretty good honestly
investing in a good chair if you're
going to be working in it
is um really really useful
yeah i mean i mean guys to be fair this
the today's
live is not meant to be the most crazy
entertaining we're watching a bunch of
small channels we're still finding their
way um
i think it's just good to
to look at them because maybe a lot of
you want to start channels maybe
you guys want to understand better what
helps a channel go from small to large
so maybe you guys can use this
information even if it's not directed at
you
hopefully it helps out so
this channel actually has 80 000 views
and she's at 63 subscribers
63k um so yeah i want to just check this
out
hello everyone welcome back to my
channel my name is brittany and for
those of you who don't know i'm obsessed
with abba and preach i think
they have okay you guys notice in six
seconds she said her name
um she said her little introduction line
and she went right to the album preach
point okay
very fast very concise anybody who's
watching understands exactly where this
is going
and if you wanted to do a reaction draw
in the admin preach users this is a good
way to start um i'm also going to say
sound quality is great
one of the most nuanced and realistic
reactions to things they find on the
internet and normally i would never
watch a jubilee video because i think
jubilee is literally the pumpkin spice
latte of content
along with buzzfeed so if you guys want
to check out my initial reaction to the
actual jubilee video
it's over on my patreon with that said i
want to react
to on youtube to auburn preach reacting
because i know they're both not in
polyamorous relationships
and that's what you think yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that's what you think
yeah when everyone says man you can only
have one girl your whole life and then
i'm just like
polyamory baby
all right all right i'm explaining i'm
not in a polyamorous relationship
because i lived in an open and
polyamorous relationship for 10 years
i want to go ahead and talk about my
experiences especially since
now i have decided to be purely
monogamous
i want to talk about why that is and i
want to see if they kind of talk about
it themselves
so if you guys want links down below for
their video please go check them out
i'm not going in front you i'm a big fan
of this like 70s hair like i [ __ ] with
it
i don't know what it was about ladies
from the 70s but whenever you look at
old pictures like
i don't know what it is like this whole
70s and 80s areas but some of these
broads like yo
i was a whole big fan of the afro look
even like the whole style like i mean
you know
the white girls didn't have fat asses
back then but you know it's still all
right
but the hair doing like the way that
people dressed
like i just [ __ ] with it maybe i'm
crazy like oh my god like yo if a sister
came up to me
in these outfits i'm like girl
how's austin powers doing you trying to
bang
you know what i'm saying let's talk do
you like psychedelics you must
it's the 70s everybody [ __ ] with
psychedelics but good lord
i just approve yes sister wear them over
us
okay you just came down from up from
mississippi another new york let's go
hey hey we got the fur jacket [ __ ] the
animals let's go
she got some fake ass snakeskin let's go
hey get down on it you already know my
man got his shirt open
let's go come on bro how you going to
tell me this air didn't have some of the
coolest looking clothes
even white girls was popping look at
them
right they look like ice cream cones
right they they look like uh
they look like popsicles but i approve
no bra
with your little titties let's go
let's go hey yeah this is how they used
to stretch in the 70s
with your green skirt on come on man
stop playing with me
it's fire
okay all right man
okay i approve of this okay
i approve of this okay so you know shout
out to shout out to
shout out to britney simon okay i
approve this hairstyle now
let's get back to this video
subscribe they're really really
insightful and just honestly really real
people and on youtube that's really hard
to find so
okay great intro great energy
visual quality is awesome look at the
framing like i was telling you guys not
too much space above the head
i actually prefer it tighter but that's
a subjective thing i think this framing
is great
um let's see what it looks like during
the video
okay only thing i would say is now that
you are reacting to the video
the framing is a little bit [ __ ] up i
would have probably zoomed in on you
and then put the that's what we do for
our videos if you notice once we're
reacting to the content
we zoom in a little bit so that the
content that we're playing is not hiding
us right so don't hesitate to crop
inward
uh just to get a better frame um
so that would be my advice on that point
um yeah if i'm looking at it it seems
like she's talking for most of the
period this is a lengthy video
seems to uh seems like she's got a lot
to say on the topic which is always good
uh audience engagement's good so yeah
all
all in all i approve
let's see here
okay so she's topical she posts
regularly
she covers all range wide of topics i
like the thumbnails
um is she wearing elf ears
yo my girl's wearing elf ears let's
[ __ ] go lord of the rings in this
[ __ ] yeah you thought i was
going to hate on you for the elfies hell
nah bro i play dungeons and dragons i'm
a nerd
for real for real if you guys want to go
check that out go to abba atlas on
youtube
if you want to see me play dmb hey
she back why i'm no longer a bdsm
educator okay see i want to click on
[ __ ] like that
this is a great title one line a few
words
the words that matter in caps look at
the thumbnail see that thumbnail who's
not clicking on that okay i'm clicking
on this one
i love simple thumbnails the simpler the
better this is also really great what
you did with the outline
right here um oh damn this looks like a
brazer logo
is she middle eastern is she lebanese
she lebanese are egyptian
abba and preach hey everyone welcome
back to my channel my name is brady
simon
and today oh she's middle eastern
brother i just thought she was regular
white
that's crazy she must be like half she
looks like she half
she gonna say she's israeli
and of course i am the child of
immigrants my parents are from iraq we
are
iraq iraq okay i'm just glad you didn't
say uh my parents are from iraq
because then i would be like [ __ ] stop
lying iraq
i don't know okay i'm not even going
french oh man
so i knew there's one dude uh he has
this he had this
thick ass accent okay super thick accent
and i would always ask him for him where
he's from and he'd be like
i'm from afghanistan or something and
every time i would talk to him a week
later i'm like hey man
you know who it is it's chris from
iraq he's like no no no i'm from
afghanistan and i was like man same
thing right
it's not the same thing i was just being
i was being ignorant idiot
but i just wanted to say every time he
would tell me where he's from i'm like
bro are you from iraq
or afghanistan you would always get mad
uh brad proof i didn't expect that she
would be from iraq
i don't know why i'm yelling that uh
overall really highly recommend i think
she's uh
doing really good for herself sometimes
you can have really great
content and just people haven't seen it
yet so
[Music]
as far as britney simon goes i think
she's doing great stuff i think she's
just gonna have to hit our stride
eventually when one video blows up and
then a bunch of people come in but
you know good for her uh
so with that we are going to move on to
the next group
everybody drop trouble one in the chat
for iraq
and uh britney simon yeah would you guys
expect a girl named britney simon to be
from iraq
not me bro not me
bro maybe she's one of those immigrants
like those chinese people who come here
and uh basically change the name that
they have for their kids
hold up yo you know what let me let me
make sure that this chat is not feeling
compressed
now you guys are doing fine
let me just just to invite anybody
trying to spam i'm going to put in a
slow mode for 20 seconds
okay nothing too crazy iraq
all right shout out to iraq man let's go
all right let's go let's uh let me read
a couple super chats and then i'll get
on to the next group
all right the experience with chris theo
i love both your content
by the way i meant you will preach i
appreciate you bro i wish more people
would help us smaller channels hey man
listen
listen you got to help yourself bro i'm
going to give you guys a bit of tips and
tricks
but honestly most of the information
that you need is on the internet you got
to just do some research and really help
yourself
bro keep up the good work you're really
funny by the way can i have some of your
subs
[Laughter]
hey man y'all y'all really shooting your
shot i appreciate y'all
i'm just saying you money at this point
because i support what you guys do what
up
fellow cisgendered folks yes sir yes sir
how do you do the do that you do amen i
just wake up baby boop
pause unless you're a girl then it's
like yo it's
on brother um iraq
all right i don't know why i keep saying
it like that let's just keep moving
so all right this guy's name is grind
and
motivate okay
all right grind and motivate
so we're gonna be reacting to his
channel okay i'm gonna be watching his
video
and we'll see how this goes he was
pertinent to
what's going on y'all grinding motivate
back in this day again with another
reaction video this time i'm reacting to
uh
pretty big youtubers abba and preach
okay
so right here okay i don't mind the
video quality i don't mind the grayness
of it it's not ideal
but it's okay the sound quality is what
matters
and so i would spend the time to watch
this video and to listen throughout
as long as what he's saying is
interesting okay
uh if you can at some point obviously
upgrade your camera just
crop it in you're a little bit too far
out you know what i'm saying brother you
spent all that time on your locks you
got your beard looking tight
all right the ladies are going to
appreciate that just zoom in a little
bit all right me personally
keep it zoomed out i don't want to see
more of your face but other ladies might
feel differently
also your expressiveness your details
are going to come a lot better if the
framing is better
okay so rather than zooming in get your
camera a little bit closer if you can
okay uh sound quality though very good
you sound really crisp i don't hear any
hissing noise
uh a1 good good job good job they
normally do reaction videos so there's a
reaction to the reaction this time
they're going over
a darius m video so i felt like it was
pertinent to you know what i'll be
talking about all the time
and i watched like the beginning of it
but i had to cut it off so i can come
back and you know see what's going on
with it
um the title of the video is it's your
duty to destroy her ego
by calling her obese dot dot why
and uh i mean like i like i mess with
like the red pill audiology and
everything but
all right he's good he's concise he
speaks well um he gets to the point you
feel like there's not too much wasting a
time between sentences so i think in
terms of
keeping things concise and someone
watching for the first time he's doing
those things very well
um all right let me just see here
ladies okay so he's doing that same
mistake
that britney was doing earlier right see
the framing
you guys notice that it's hiding half of
his face even when he's paused
you got to fix that right because people
want to see you when you're talking
generally not always everyone's always
going to want to see you but
it's definitely off-putting if the
creator you're trying to pay attention
to
is cut off by his own editing you don't
generally want that all right
um
women when they're rejecting due to be
outright outlandishly
validating it yourself you're validating
what do you mean
now and also
okay another thing i would say is
probably add in more of your own
commentary okay
one thing with videos especially with
reaction channels is like people come to
see you with
and if they're not if they're mostly
watching our video then why would they
watch yours you feel me
they want to hear more from you maybe
they don't
but you should give them a reason to
want to because that makes them want to
subscribe
because then they come to your channel
to get some that they can't get anywhere
else which is your voice
your opinions your thoughts your maps
and if you don't have any opinions
generally don't don't post a video
that's my opinion
you know because it's your youtube
channel we come to see you
we want to see what your thoughts are on
matters okay so that'd be my opinion
on that specifically let me go just
check here
okay um thumbnail you got to improve the
thumbnails bro
thumbnails is probably the most
important thing the single most
important thing you could do
in order to make sure that people click
on your videos is thumb
nails okay first thing you want to do is
create simplistic thumbnails look at
this man the text
is clashing with the like the bubble
there's too many pictures of too many
things it's a mess i don't know what
this is about
i want to just i just want to click on a
video and then immediately or like not
even because i just want to look at it
and know exactly what it's about
so for example okay i'm going to go to
my youtube page
all right this my thumbnail you see my
face right there that's a good thumbnail
it pops it looks creepy you don't know
what the [ __ ] is
that's a good thumbnail okay this
is also a pretty decent thumbnail okay
you see how he's highlighted you can see
him very clearly he pops i like that
all right
let's see here good thumbnails these
this is my style of thumbnail okay since
i do commentary this sports commentary
very simple the subject right which is
the dallas mavericks very good right
there
and then the person who's talking we
know what the [ __ ] going on it's not
too much [ __ ] going on the screen
um sidemen okay
i don't really watch these guys but i
clicked on one video and it's [ __ ]
over
god bless aside man congratulations on
all your success but look at this
see this thumbnail he got his face
that's popping and then whatever's in
the background that works really well
all right so so yeah okay
let me uh so that's my thoughts on the
matter
okay so hopefully that helps you guys to
understand a little bit the thumbnail
game
all right
um fam do a live interview with skippy
hey you know what if skippy wants to
come on for a live
i'd definitely be down if you guys want
him to come on y'all should message him
and if he agrees then come holla at me
okay uh but i support you guys so keep
going
uh oh i just got a confirmation
that we may be having a very special
guest on our live
this sunday okay this special guest has
been the subject of a lot of our
interviews it's not skippy
he's but he's been the subject of two of
our videos
okay i'm not going to say who it is
i'm going to announce it a little bit
this person could be from iraq
all right so uh what song do you guys
use in your outro it's a song
um that we will be releasing i promise
some stuff is going on
and it's really crazy and i'm gonna tell
the whole story some point uh but i
can't say anything
okay all right react to mediocre
tutorial i don't need to
to act to react to mediocre tutorial and
reviews he's already doing so good
he's growing at a very fast rate he
knows what he's doing you don't need my
help
that man that man's on the right path so
i support him
all right so i'm gonna go to the next
person
all right so i've never seen these
people okay they reacted to one of our
channels
okay right away right away okay this
visual quality is on point
i also like what they did with the back
lighting over here blue
red great great great great choices
once again i would have probably zoomed
in a little bit so i
her her mouth is not hidden or his mouth
is not hidden
that would probably be my only thing
that i would say visually but right away
great um title game very good
very good um let's go my front
balcony is in the back of his video does
it have the white arches
it's the white orchid shut the f those
are recess
once again they use the same trick which
is the um go to the highlight moment
right away at the beginning so that's
that
i haven't preached that love their
channel
jackson what's happening team jackson
what's happening team jackson what's
happening
team jackson what's happening
[Music]
all right all right i'm gonna just zoom
over to a part where they start talking
yeah i love it the zoom in is like it's
like
tension but it's like and this video is
hilarious but it's like yo she yeah
it's like she reacting to his video
sound quality is a one this is
what happens when you use a good setup
plus good equipment
uh good proximity this is great this is
this is like some of the best
sound quality you're going to find i i
highly approve
um yeah this is good
this is good so what he's saying he was
the best
you his wife you was just that in the
other show
the man put it like this on that first
this dude wow
okay uh let me just check something else
i just want to say i want to check
something else before i
let me go to their most viewed video see
what's popping okay
going savage on a woman and telling her
that she's at all right i'm gonna tell
you right now i already know
this brother about to go ham because
most consultants but i'm actually
curious
i might say something you don't
a little bit on who you can you know who
you see yourself what do you qualify for
or who you qualify okay so
this is what i'm gonna say about these
two great setup i think the
dynamic could be very interesting i just
think their personalities don't come
out enough as i'm watching the video i
think with commentary and stuff like
that you want to interject when it when
it's poignant
people want to hear from you because if
we just see the full length video for
about six to eight minutes on length we
kind of forget that you're even there
and we're more focused on what you're
reacting to right
so bring out more of yourselves in the
content okay i'm not giving you guys the
same advice everyone else because your
setup is always
fantastic um from what i see
video titles audio great
so now it comes down to content and you
guys got to bring out more of yourselves
when you guys are doing this because we
want to subscribe to we random tv
okay all right not to what you're
reacting to so i need to see you guys
in the content i'm watching okay even if
that's not always interesting or
as you start it's gonna take time to get
there um even the thumbnails
thumbnails are pretty good uh sometimes
there's a little bit too much going on
you know but the simple ones like this
one that's a good that's a good
thumbnail
so just try to keep it simple that would
be my um
that'd be my advice uh and
i and i highly rate this one i think
they got a great great setup
all right
oh man all right let me come back to
this chat
not every guy's high energy i don't
think you need to be high energy that's
not the point
but you do need to be present i need to
know that you're watching and you're
part of the content that i'm about to
consume feel me so when i'm enjoying
something i want to i want to get the
idea that
i'm reacting or i'm watching somebody
who's got something that they really
want to share
okay so that's what i mean
i'm at the 15 minute mark of this live
it may seem out of place but i use a
tick of the internal record on my cell
phone yeah
honestly cell phone for recording audio
it's it's not the peak
but it's going to be serviceable for
most youtube videos so
uh yeah sending more support hey chris
patterson i mean you being super
generous today chris i appreciate you
love the content donation red sings and
blues i appreciate you
now we got the demon lord on demon time
all right
you know what i want to look at some
girls from the 70s again let me just get
creepy once more
let me let me let me just let me just do
this for a few seconds over here
come on let me look at these beautiful
ass ladies okay
damn you already know man hold up
how am i playing a song about morenas
and it's just a bunch of white girls let
me let me let me
come on bro come on be kind to me bruh
show me some latinas you know what i'm
saying show me some other flavors
it's a morena song
all right there you go there's people
who are trying to fake the funk
i approve this i didn't i was not a big
fan of like uh this [ __ ] right here
when everyone's wearing like those gym
type clothing this stuff right here
but uh otherwise it's cool
all right this is more legal oh hey
yes this was the pre this was the
the type of woman that preached was
getting rejected by
preachers going up to girls that look
like [ __ ] rainbows and they're like
uh
too gay
[Laughter]
imagine a girl like this trying to tell
you that you sound sus
[ __ ] you look like a bag of skittles
[ __ ] out of here
if a girl from the 80s rejected me
talking about
you not manly in love i'm like how bibi
you look like you got jumped by a
rainbow
out here looking like the leprechaun's
better half
okay how to dress for an 80s party
let's go let's go my man's wearing a
choker
and some gay-ass cowboy pants let's go
oh that sweater is nice though i'm not
even gonna front you if a girl showed up
with a sweater like that i'm like girl
you want to work on my computer
come on my hard drive needs some
defragments
okay it needs some cleaning baby
okay all right see this is what i'm
talking about this is this janet jackson
hairstyle
isn't this what britney simon was
rocking britney spine was rocking that
head that janet jackson
you see i'm saying this whole curly ass
thing right here let's go
oh oh whitney houston out here
out here with so much hair looking like
an amazonian goddess
i want to feel the heat with somebody
that's how you know you [ __ ] can't
sing
let's go stop playing with me
all right morena
all right let's go
so
let us react to yet another small whoa
what's this all right
next channel okay her name is uh
vinnie mas okay she sounds and looks
super foreign
but that is not the point of the video
hi all it's me video welcome back to my
channel
oh oh [ __ ] dear this beat goes hard
i i normally don't like when people do
subscribe at the beginning
but i'm gonna allow it just because this
bee goes heartening me and welcome back
to my channel
today i'm going to talk about oh hell
now play that [ __ ] back
i don't care if it was four seconds is
this how you guys feel when i play the
outro
yo we'll play that [ __ ] back
today i'm going to talk about nah nah
play that [ __ ] back stop playing with me
i don't want to hear about nothing else
welcome back to my channel
today hey [ __ ] i want to go to a club
asap let's go
i want to go to a club stop playing with
me
hey this is my type of [ __ ] i like this
kind of music hey all it's me video
welcome back to my channel
today i'm going to oh man that [ __ ] goes
hard bro
that [ __ ] goes hard you know what this
kind of makes me think of
this is not like this perfectly but this
this [ __ ] was pretty far i'm not even
gonna lie
was it this one
oh yeah this [ __ ] was hard
oh let's go
okay all right i'm gonna stop
[Music]
just kidding yeah yep right
that [ __ ] goes hard i don't care what
nobody says
you already know all right all right all
right
all right she for the streets okay all
right all right
all right all right all right all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna stop that let's get
back to the stream
okay okay all right let's go back to our
intro
i'm sorry no more tangents let's just go
back to being professional
whoa talk about this one particular
video you guys
i really like them i just found them
yesterday i watched like probably
okay all right first off visuals a1
audio absolutely not
all right i don't know what that hissing
noise is i don't know if she's filming
this
right beside her fridge but that [ __ ] is
loud as hell and it's
true i really like them i just found
them yesterday i watched like probably
three to four videos i wake up on delay
if she finds whatever is causing that
giant ass hissing noise i think it's
going to fix a lot of her issues right
here
all right i think she needs to get
closer maybe set up like i would
honestly say if you can't
if you have a problem with loud noise
take your cell phone
put it right beside your mouth hold it
like you would if you were a reporter
and talk into it and then in post
editing like don't don't let it peak
but as long as you're like close enough
you can then edit out any other noise
because you're so close to your sound
source okay
that'd be my first advice visuals though
a1 some natural lighting
the lighting looks very natural on her
the framing is a1
i approve it's 2 a.m because of their
videos i
laughed my ass off you already know
what the young boy can't do hey
shoot up yay girl
go tell me fellas have you seen her
yo y'all yeah i think i don't know a bit
of see breezy some chris brown
yay girl
yeah hold up you think i'm playing
that's exactly how that song goes bro
hold up let me let me let me pull that
[ __ ] up
chris brown [ __ ] it called
ain't that exactly how that [ __ ] goes
[Music]
yay
anyways i'm not going to play the whole
thing uh let's go back
all right let me go back to this [ __ ]
right here
[Music]
all right all right all right all right
all right there we go let me go this is
way
too funny because they really have a
very good insight you know they
are so mature you know in seeing things
and
okay i don't know what country this
girl's from uh the accent's uh
i'm with it there's lots of frasier i
think out of like the social media
that's why even though english is not a
first language he speaks clearly i
approve
it seems like for the most part of the
video she's adding a lot of commentary
throughout that's exactly what you want
after that it's just a matter of like
making the content interesting right
and doing it consistently until you pop
um
she talks about stuff like kim and
samuel's topical thing so this is good
there seems to be some through lines um
and those seem to be our most popular
video makes sense
is this her son hello it's me video
welcome back to my channel so today i
am with my son okay i think these people
are the are they philippines philippines
filipino
i approve okay cool um
what other advice i would have the
thumbnails could use some work
thumbnails like this work really well
there's her and then there's the word
but when you put the words in white i
would put like an outline around it so
it pops a little bit better
but overall her setup is very clean this
is good
this is a this is a good setup after
that is just getting better at the
content
more interesting bringing that out of
yourself but i like what she's doing
that's pretty much my only advice uh let
me just see if she does this
welcome back to my channel
okay just just the whole the subscribe
thing throw that in the middle
okay throw that in the middle it'll work
a lot better for you
i'll give you guys an example
okay these guys are hilarious all right
they're crazy okay
obviously they're getting thrown out
they've been booted off youtube a few
times already because their content's
too crazy crazy
look how it starts look how it starts it
already starts on the crazy [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] did i just ah [ __ ] i shouldn't
have played that
let me just turn that off see what i
mean these these
they're too crazy bro
okay [ __ ] i shouldn't have played that
anyways all right i'm gonna i'm trying
i'm gonna try not to think about it
okay so uh this is kel
and jtv they got 32k subscribers
um so yeah i'm gonna check out their
video and see and see what's going on
all right so let's uh let's go
okay right away this like first five six
seconds
never ask people to subscribe in the
first seven seconds
okay and i'll tell you why i click on
your video
i'm only going to spend 30 seconds to
give you a chance if you're lucky
so you want to go right into it and hook
me you don't want to tell people to buy
your product off the top you want to
explain why your product is good
by just demonstrating your product right
and your product is your content
so when you start a video just start
right going into it
today's topic or whatever you got to do
and just get right into it to hook
people in a funny moment
don't go so there you go what is up you
guys welcome back to the channel it's
your girl jay here back with another
video
sound quality very good visuals very
clean
i would probably crop it there's like
half the screen is just above her head
that's not necessary
today we are going to be checking out a
video by ava and preach i'm definitely a
huge fan of their channel
hey girl we appreciate you um she she
talks very clearly i approve of
all this stuff um so yeah i'm just going
to skip right into it
when like you when you're not
necessarily aware of like that i'm
watching
what do i do okay
it was like okay
and i and there's like a question they
actually a question in their eyes girl
they didn't even say
okay another mistake she's making she's
talking over the video mixing up the
audio
just pause it and just say what you got
to say even if it's short
i'd rather hear you and and not have to
like have my focus confused because i
couldn't miss something interesting
you're trying to say
or you could be missing out on making a
great point so just pause the video just
start talking okay
uh don't don't overlay that footage
unless you're like you're laughing
generally speaking
i didn't really know what that's like
okay
okay good um
and it's usually because okay it seems
like she does quite a bit of talking
actually
uh she spends most of the time
it's usually women men don't give a crap
oh my god then why wendy's ridiculous
you know okay um she seems charismatic i
would tell you
spend more time talking more time
sharing experiences maybe things that
you've gone through share more of your
input
i think in doing so more of yourself
will come out in the video and the
viewer is going to
much more likely subscribe because they
want to hear from you
right so add more of yourself in the
video i'm not saying you got to force it
um but don't hesitate that's what i
would tell you
um yeah that'd be my advice
seems like she's doing pretty well 32k
subscribers that's cool
yeah post videos pretty regularly
reacting to all kinds of stuff
okay i don't know how much of her own
commentary she adds in all these videos
uh but i think the way to succeed on
this platform doing any form of reaction
in my opinion
is to add your own opinions and your
commentary or and people might say like
what if i have nothing to say then
traditionally try to react to things
that you have
things to say you know that would be my
advice
uh all right and then we got this girl
okay
this was only a four minute video her
name is kenisha
toktu it sounds like it could be south
african
i'm not really sure uh maybe zimbabwe
who knows doesn't matter let me uh just
play the video and let's see what she
got thanks family it's kenisha
i am back with another video in today's
video
what did she say family is canisius
hatching
okay maybe i was wrong i thought this
was a
a different type of name she sounds very
american so maybe i don't know what the
[ __ ] i'm talking about
um
sound quality right off the top is not
that great
visuals is phenomenal though she did a
great job with the framing
um i don't really care about what's
going on in the background to me it's
not that important doesn't distract too
hard
so pretty good start today's video we're
going to be reacting to abba and preach
dismissing white supremacy and
trivializing
black oppression
oh hell yeah okay i gotta watch the
whole thing this is about to get juicy
juicy
okay i'm curious to hear what she's
gonna have to say
okay let me uh just check out some super
chats and then we about to go in my
[ __ ]
all right here we go bruh abba when are
you starting that anime chat i already
started i've done a few livestream go to
abba listen you can find it there rodney
platt
hey great content as someone that's
getting into content creation seeing
this helps me see how i can improve my
setup
i am happy to do that sir this advice is
free but i do appreciate the donation
all the way from europe i'm assuming
from the uk thank you good sir street
mint logos
thank you for your donor i'm not
allowing anyone to buy my reviews i'm
just helping out young creators
red stings in the blues one more time
taking notes giving smaller channels
rays to grow that's right
helping y'all try to help you can you
give my gamer channel true nice
hey man if people see it they see it
love your guys's work please keep it up
thank you jesus
demon lord thank you shanim togo
damn girl i like your name how you doing
gang gang shout out
from the real and then we got prince
ragita thank you for the donno lando
brahms thank you
moki i'm out here doing part for the
community i'm trying to help
marquis lewis mba
20 thank you for donation and demon lord
on demon time can you please
react review my reaction channel
unfortunately i'm not allowing anyone to
tell me
which ones because i don't want to take
money to do this i'm doing this just
because i can all right
if i if i um if i were to take money
i think it would kind of ruin the whole
process right so i'm just doing this for
free if you get reacted to great if you
don't
you know i'm saying it is what it is all
right so
let's go right here now look obviously
you guys are going to see the dislikes
and likes and you guys are going to
judge the video me i just like listening
to the person
and seeing what they have to say now
obviously the first sentence you know
but let's hear the person out people are
great at having
fun that's a function great job with the
framing i love
i love how she cut it in half you see
her and you see the video clearly
like listen it's irrespective of what
she thinks about my video her setup is
great
of white supremacy
okay the reason why i had that reaction
which i probably would have liked if she
included
was before i predicted why i thought the
guy was gonna say
why why people suck and i'm like don't
say it and then three seconds later he
confirmed what i thought he was gonna
say so that's why i ran off okay but
anyways
let's play the video
[Music]
this is a function of white supremacy
under the umbrella
um yeah [ __ ] it is a function of
white supremacy
oh this is going to be good let me get
right it's very true what that brother
said because
white people are the only ones that are
able to have true fun
you know white people could literally
allocate another part of america
to black people but they refuse to do
that because dominating us is fun to
them
okay the video is out of sync so that's
like always a problem you want to make
sure it's in sync
something weird about seeing someone's
lips move and the audio is not right it
drives me [ __ ]
nuts um
okay now to what she's saying the idea
that only white people can have real fun
amen okay
white supremacy is fun to white people
you have open like
[Music]
white supremacy is fun to white people
oh my god
you guys can't hear her
i'll i'll turn her up i'll turn her up
let me let me just play back what she
said
um yeah [ __ ] it is a function of
white supremacy that's very true what
that brother said because white people
are the only ones that are able to have
true fun
you know white people could literally
allocate another part of america
to black people but they refuse to do
that because dominating
us is fun to them why
i don't know for all my black people who
are in the chat
okay all my black people are you guys
capable of having true fun in your
opinion
have there been moments in your life
where you were having true fun
did white supremacy come ruin it for you
uh you know
i'm gonna try to be as open-minded as i
can be
i i i don't know this is i can't take
this kind of stuff seriously
are you guys walking through life every
single day incapable of having fun due
to white supremacy
is that a real thing for you guys
am i crazy
maybe i just don't see it maybe this is
completely over my head
from all my time living in america
from all my time living in america and
all my homies all my needs out there
when i was living in the states
i never got the impression that the only
times they couldn't have fun
was due to white supremacy but anyways
i digress
okay white people out here ruling in fun
supremacy
is fun to white people you have open
white supremacists
like richard spencer that has came out
and said out his mouth
that white supremacy is fun the kkk
started off as a joke jim crow started
off as a joke
and white supremacists have meshed
dominating
and having fun so it's business and
pleasure for them
i mean okay but do you think that's the
highest form of fun
white supremacy is the highest form of
fun really
like have you never been on a water
slide you don't think a water slide is
more fun than
what about lake i don't know man i'm not
even confront you like i had
i'd had a girl like suck the soul out of
my penis
that [ __ ] was fun as [ __ ] now if i
compare that to white supremacists
running around burning down buildings
do i think that they had more fun than
me probably not
probably not because while they were
burning crosses bro
i was selling my soul to the devil this
girl sucked the [ __ ]
tsunami alert that [ __ ] was wild bro
you know and you know i imagine that's
got to be
way more fun than white supremacy right
you know you know what else is fun you
have a long day of work you're driving
back you're
like 20 steps away from your door you
need to [ __ ] like crazy
then you [ __ ] just blow from the car
door to the home
you rush to the bathroom you take a huge
dump that sounds like tremendous fun
you know what else is fun in life
what else is fun in life i don't know
the [ __ ] do i know i don't like how i've
been preacher minimizing white supremacy
as you can see they couldn't make a
statement to debunk what that
brother had to say so now they just
mocking him
i mean you can't debunk something that
just sounds so absurd
white people are the only ones capable
of having fun
is your life really that miserable due
to white folks don't get me wrong i
understand why supremacy is a thing
and it's a problem granted but you're
incapable of having fun
okay and it's either true or is not true
you know
and what they're doing right now is
trivializing
black oppression so what i would argue
i would argue that blaming white
supremacy for everything
is trivializing white supremacy because
then it means nothing
okay habibi if you're not able to have
fun in your day-to-day life that's not
white supremacy's fault
it's because you got a boring ass
schedule bro
go chase an ice cream truck
jump on a swing set
push a kid when nobody's looking that
[ __ ] is fun as [ __ ]
and you can control it push a white kid
it might make it more fun
put a hood on his head now he's a white
supremacist push him on the floor
nobody's looking you're gonna feel
amazing there's so many things in life
that you can do
to make your life more fun and that's on
you baby
okay you know what i mean
that's on you okay
so that's that that'd be my advice to
you let's keep watching
i need you know alba to do is go back to
his homeland where they cutting coochie
lips off
[Laughter]
she said go back to your homeland when
they cut kumchi lips off
let me see here
it was a good one that was funny
how common is it i know it was common i
just never knew the numbers
god damn we out here that means sudan
and eritrea and all these other
countries are outpacing us but you know
what i mean
we cutting coochie lips less and less
every day you know i mean
right but you know what's interesting
is like you talk about white supremacy
is the reason why they're not having fun
but even in black country we cutting off
coochie lips so we don't let you have
fun
so is that white supremacy's fault huh
nah we cut off the coochie lips because
we said ladies you're not supposed to
have fun
that's not white supremacy
but i digress i'm just having a good old
laugh
all right let's keep playing
and for priest to go back to wherever
the [ __ ] he's from because both of these
two
are immigrants and they live in canada
and you can tell that they try to
emulate you know black culture by how
they dress and how they talk
but then they [ __ ] on black culture by
minimizing white supremacy
uh i digress we just disagree [ __ ]
on black culture would be
us saying that blacks or apes or
disgusting or black culture is repulsive
or
you know all this other stuff i don't
think we ever have rhetoric like that
in fact we got love for our black
brothers and sisters
sometimes we just disagree on what the
path forward is and that's great we're
not a monolith we can all have
disagreements
but you know you can't just look at
everything and go well based on their
geography of course they wouldn't oh
well first off i've lived in the states
for many many years
secondly there's plenty of americans who
share the exact same opinion and
sentiment as us
are they also you know [ __ ] on black
culture because they happen to disagree
with your view
what these are are ways to try to
discredit someone's
ability to participate in a conversation
based off of factors that really don't
have much bearing
on the importance of the the opinion
you feel what i'm saying so
when people people do that basically
just they don't want to argue what you
actually said so they just want to go
throw these things in to be like
you shouldn't even listen to this person
and trivializing black oppression here
you're at
oppression gaslighting lack of empathy
intellectualizing oppression did i say
oppression
they're just creatively thinking of new
ways of like always staying one step
ahead of
other people we get rid of slave
catchers and let's just expand the
police force
as the the video progresses get lighter
and lighter
um i want you all to notice how
they keep going off topic and talking
about inconsequential things
instead of debunking what that sister
had to say
the reason why we didn't debunk
everything the sister had to say
was because the fact that these are
topics we've all recovered numerous
times
the video is called what are white
people good at now we were kind of
curious to hear what we were going to
say
we didn't know it would turn into a trap
right well really what it was
was just a video to like [ __ ] on white
folks that's what it was
if they would have just said hey this is
a video where you [ __ ] on white folks we
probably would have come at it to
deconstruct them more
we thought we was gonna have some fun
what are white people good at you could
have said casserole
you could have said uh clowns you know
they're great
you know scary movies like who asked you
running into buildings they have no
business being like haunted buildings
who asked you you know
um [ __ ] with the dead uh weird
fetishes there's so many things that
white people are phenomenal at
that we could have gotten into that are
fun but this video had to go straight to
white people are evil and white people
white supremacy white supremacy white
supremacy
it's just like all right this is this
got dull so at some point you just gotta
have a laugh
okay but if you'd like to see our
opinions on
a lot of race related issues there's
there they're there on the
channel but we're not going to do that
every video it gets redundant it gets
boring
hey they just going off topic talking
about dumb [ __ ] what doesn't matter
if people are getting lighter as the
video progresses
preach you lay it up with a whole
full-fledged white woman
and white supremacy is a generalization
okay because
i cut the video off but the rest of the
video they was talking about how
oh y'all need to stop generalizing white
folks white supremacy is a
generalization in itself because
all white people generally benefit from
it it is not an
individual thing she is
correct on the the that point
and the everyday white supremacist looks
like your wife preached
oh man it's lost get it girl
get him so both of these two [ __ ] need
to shut their mouths
when it comes to racism because they
don't understand it obviously
and they don't know what they're talking
about and i know ivan preach likes to
respond
back to people you know who make videos
about them
and i i just want to let them know bring
that cloud over here because i know
just like y'all got autumn white
suspected white supremacists
that support your youtube i have
grassroots black people
they're supporting me as well how baby
why are we going to work we don't have
to go to war
why does it need to turn into a big-ass
conflict nobody trying to fight
yeah but a fight with white supremacy
every day means we got to go to
chill we could just have a disagreement
have a conference now when i fight for
my existence i'm like all right you know
what
then we're not going to have a
conversation we don't have it doesn't
have to be so confrontational
jesus but let me just keep playing this
so i dare you to respond back to this
good
damn i i didn't know i was going to
stumble on this by accident
oh my god bro this is crazy i felt like
yo you know what this feels like bro
i'm not even gonna front you this okay
this feels like i activated her trap
card like this girl
like like she just got excited and she
just pulled like uh
it you know what i'm saying i feel like
i'm looking at this [ __ ]
she going in
yay girl checking that i just gave
you all and this was a checking that's
fine
back to this good checking that i just
gave you all
and this was a very teachable moment
okay we have to start calling out
you know these people that try to
minimize white supremacy
yet they trying to copy everything you
know black americans do
so i just want to thank you guys so much
for watching
don't forget to you you know what's so
interesting about this stuff
and it's something i've i've clocked in
on a lot
when it comes to the pan-african
movement when it comes to
a lot of dances when it comes to a lot
of uh musical influences
black americans you know there seems to
be a giant divide between oftentimes
black americans and africans from africa
right a lot of conflict between the two
and they're constantly taken from each
other whether it be outfits whether it
be
movies like [ __ ] black panther
whether it be
you know hip-hop influence on african uh
a lot of different african music and you
know african influences on a lot of
america
you know there's interesting like
sharing
and then conflict all the time you know
and
when people are like you want to steal
from michael
steele [ __ ] been sharing and
taking from each other's cultures
forever
you know so that's just the one thing
that's always interesting and the second
thing is
i think when this discussion happens
some people are so convinced that
they're right when they're having these
topics
that if you disagree with them
rather than looking at the substantive
part of your argument what they're going
to do is be like
well the reason why you disagree is
because your mom is from ethiopia
and the reason why you disagree is
because your white wife is white
and you're laying with the white
supremacist which is laying with the
enemy therefore you are now a traitor to
it's a lot of this stuff and this is so
useless for discourse
so such a waste of time um but i do
think that she knows how to say her
points
i do think um she knows what she's
getting at
but i think if you're trying to gauge
like serious discourse into
serious debate doing so with such a smug
and condescending attitude probably
doesn't get your point across because
i'll be honest with you the video you
reacted to that was not our attempt
at serious commentary we went in there
jovially and having a laugh
okay and the cut which is not a channel
known for serious commentary
it's probably not what we're going to
react to and we haven't want to have a
serious discussion about a very
difficult topic
so understand the room when you're
having this discussion
okay if you want to be serious and have
you know art and discussions about
whites
there's nothing wrong with that and i
think there's a place in time for that
but to think our video was that
kind of odd in my opinion but
overall in terms of quality i would rate
this video probably an eight out of ten
very explosive straight to the point she
knows how to get right in there
the sound quality is not the best as i
kept listening i heard more and more
hissing noises
as well as the um visual being out of
sync
but you know she knows how to captivate
you like or hate it
she is someone you want to listen to she
gets straight to the point she knows how
to say her
her points very clearly and concisely so
i give her an 8 out of 10. i highly
recommend woodwatch again
that's my thoughts
um but i digress i uh
wanted to just talk about that and let's
go read off some of these super chats
and while i'm reading off some of these
super chats let me just play play a bit
of that song for you know what i'm
saying
all right thank you to
the dating doc is green screen played
out for studio setup
i personally don't like um i personally
don't like it
green screen joey thank you for the
donation kel
kell and jtv hey we reacted to you guys
thank you for coming out
charles edward cheese with the 500 don't
know hey let's go
okay we'll have a little dance break
hey hey let's go you already know
wow that was beautiful that was
beautiful you already know i'm very
proud of my boy for that trek
okay okay uh prep black people can't
have fun she obviously hasn't been to a
black cookout that's what i'm saying i'm
like
yo you know what i think black people
have so much fun that a lot of folks
want to join in on our movements
on our art forms on their dances like if
you think about the most famous dances
and forms of art in the world generally
they are often done
uh by black folks not all but a lot of
them and i think people recognize the
joy in it if you think about like party
atmosphere music
things like that that's a lot of what we
do and so i think facilitating a good
time creating a great atmosphere it's
like
personally this is what i always say all
right i don't know how you guys feel
about this
i always say you can't have a party
without black people but you can't have
a party with just black folks either
yeah i'm saying
because sometimes some real [ __ ] goes
down um
but overall i just disagree with their
sentiment
kell and jtv appreciate the advice i
know thank you jase winston you know
what else is fun sitting on a white
man's platform telling them oh my god
all right
anya's heart thank you for the donation
and evangeline thank you
she just told abba to go back to africa
yes she did she really said that [ __ ]
were they cutting off coochie lips god
damn [ __ ]
she seems very rashy
kenny sherry hey kenny sherry how you
doing
one dollar a all the way from canada
let's go girl smash ball heart of cards
thank you
sir all right uh
although you know what you know what you
guys are donating so much let me play a
little bit of that track again
all right courtney mans thank you lando
brands black panther came on february
white supremacists are pandering extra
onions
couldn't drop more poor country keep up
the good thank you sir i appreciate the
donation regardless extra onions
hello d i just found your channel
weekend i love it i literally been
binge watching your videos hey i
appreciate your girlfriend
ajax the juggalo thank you something to
watch
i'm dropping a deuce as we speak all
right melania
melania turner thank you for the dono
and vimo thank you cam haley
oh hailey okay this is ethiopian i'm
eritrean habesha what i tell you
i live in germany
i live in germany and i never had a
girlfriend because
no confidence i am broke also but i
appreciate the 10
donation and i would like to date a
white girl
let me read that [ __ ] back i am eritrean
habesha too
i live in germany and i've never had a
girlfriend because
no confidence i am broke also and i
would like to date a white girl
i think it is a thing to date a white
girl
as no white i don't know what the [ __ ]
that phrase man bro
cute black housewife
yo y'all reacted to me when i was in a
jubilee video
i'm the girl who asked about the ears oh
i think i know which video she's talking
about
i think i know exactly
i think it's this [ __ ] right here
i hear this one we make assumptions
about people all the time
um can she show her ears
this moment right here killed me
um could she show her ears
yo that was such a [ __ ] random thing
to say
that was funny though i'm not even gonna
frustrate shout out to you
uh ben deguire says abba doesn't like it
when you tell him to dance but he'll
sure do it for money
hey i mean you want to drop 500 i'm not
mad at you i like dancing i absolutely
love dancing it's something i enjoy
doing you don't have to pay me if you
just play a good track that i enjoy i'll
probably start dancing that's just me
i just don't like when people like dance
for me like i'm a monkey like i'm there
for your experience like i like to dance
for me
feel me all right when i look good
it's for me baby all right
okay she show her ears yo i got big ass
ears i'm not even confront you
uh malonia turner thank you thank you
ma'am again
keep watching crispy and nilo what is
the biggest piece of advice you would
give to young black men
amen be brave
be brave and be smart those are the two
things i would tell you if you operate
with those two things in mind in life
whether it be your business your love
life all these things
you're gonna be doing good so those are
my thoughts
all right let's go uh but you know what
okay
all right
here we go and you know
some people are like why would you leave
that comment i think it's just good to
have a little bit of a laugh we don't
want to take each other too seriously
and you know i don't care if i have a
million subscribers and they only have a
thousand like i don't
i don't look at people that way i don't
i don't judge people's like validity
and their opinions based off of how many
subscribers they have like that doesn't
matter
um to me she's like
what's your opinion does it hold some
water yeah great then let's go with that
uh but beyond that i don't um
but i don't care about numbers you could
you could be a person with two million
subscribers i don't care it's not that
doesn't change anything for me
and as far as like whether what i feel
about her personally it doesn't change
my rating of her
the quality of her work because someone
can have the worst opinion in the world
and the quality of their work is still
great they could still be super
charismatic
super talented uh great setup uh
you know poignant content right so if
you have those things
your work is still amazing all right so
sometimes people gotta take themselves
out of what they like
versus what is actually good because i
can tell you she's someone who's very
watchable so
um yeah
all right here we go back with the
mother [ __ ]
what's up y'all i wish katie was teddy
what's good he was buddy what's goody
what's betty what's up
goodie is your girl zz back with another
[ __ ] video
okay uh one quick tip try not to swear
in the first 30 seconds
your video always gets demonetized they
don't play with this [ __ ]
otherwise high energy very charismatic
you know what i'm saying good for here i
turn on my notifications this video a
thumbs up
share this [ __ ] okay the intro
is too long
we gotta we gotta get this [ __ ] moving
15 seconds you still telling me to
comment subscribe
come on hi bb let's get to it okay so
today's video is going to be a reaction
active we're on board that's the only
thing that matters
but for ladies height tension okay i
guess you watch this video
and she didn't turn off the audio from
her room when she was reacting and she
was doing the post editing
now there's an echo something you want
to avoid doing it really [ __ ] with
audio quality
more important like she literally
like used to have and she's not like
that anymore but she literally had like
a
criteria like you had forgotten i think
you had to be like at least
[Applause]
my heels on people see him and me and
they think he's my
see what i'm talking about the echo
trash brother that's kind of
spawned with when i say tall when i say
height is a it matters to me height does
kind of matter to me i'm not
audio quality is great video i don't
mind i don't like the fact that she's
facing away from the camera face towards
the camera at least something
comparable right if you're facing like
sideways you're like looking over your
shoulder
you kind of look like a [ __ ] jojo
character like you're going to strike a
weird pose how maybe just look into the
camera
or look towards it okay it'll help
people all right people want to see that
you have two shoulders that matters
i promise you it matters to each other
you might want a [ __ ]
you might want to be [ __ ] you might
want a little bit like that's just up to
[ __ ]
she's very charismatic overall i can see
why she's already at 10k she's doing
good in terms of like her presence
let me see if she's consistent okay all
right
uh i like these thumbnail these
thumbnails right here
oh my god goldman sachs committing 10
billion
okay
okay okay oh she do
long ass videos god damn
what the [ __ ] was that let me play this
[ __ ] back what was that did she just
fart
in the first two seconds
[Laughter]
[Music]
let me play that [ __ ] man y'all heard
that chat am i crazy
no let me put up the volume bro
listen if a girl makes that sound right
after taking some of your dick bro
that's how you know you're giving good
dick yeah
yo chad give put a one in the chat if
you ever want your girl to say some
noise like this
oh man if a girl sit on your dick and
that's the first noise that she made
hey man you hitting them sugar walls the
right way yeah yeah yeah
hey man listen hey listen man it's
orgasms on the beat
yeah what are joints called the little
wind joints they get energy from a
couple of them joints was frozen over or
whatever
um but majority of the power source is
from natural gas whatever so yeah
okay she does like conspiracy type stuff
and crazy [ __ ] like that
or like just like giant things cool man
i'm mad at her
i matter it's different it's different
she uh she
she looks like she's using like the
instagram live i would tell her my
strategy for her would be like to cut up
little clips and highlights
and then put them in here that are
easily titled uh the title's
not that appealing maybe for her fan
base they would click most other people
would not
and the thumbnails are i wouldn't
recommend the thumbnails
like thumbnails like this are good but
you got to have a good title you know
what i'm saying
but i'm just saying this is my advice
for people who are making long-form
content like this
if you look at kevin samuels and what he
does well
okay all right
okay he uses a bunch of stock images
which are already kind of appealing
sometimes like
this is pretty good like but look at the
look at that look at the title very
simple our modern women ready
okay these are very clickable titles all
right
he's got his long form videos which are
two hours then he's got his short form
videos which work really well to kind of
accentuate that
because [ __ ] i'm not watching a three
hour stream no way but i'll watch a nine
minute video
right i'll watch um
i'll watch a 32 minute video you know
what i'm saying like this i'll click on
this
see if cameron samuels was not super
talented
i would think that this whole intro is
unnecessary but because of the fact that
people [ __ ] with his [ __ ] so much and
they've already watched it they're gonna
tolerate the
intro also the song's kind of bang i'm
not even going to front you bro i have
to look it up let's just type
want to talk about do you want to talk
about the settling or do you want to
talk about the
10 billion 10 billion several things
okay so the first thing you hit on was
eggs
why does it always have to be from a
woman's perspective none of men's
say again what is always going to be
from a woman's perspective and not
immense
why does it always have to be from a
woman's perspective
yes what are you referring to
hi bibi only women have eggs
as you guys age it becomes harder for
you to give birth
that's why it's probably from a woman's
perspective
what that's like talking about
testicular cancer
and little and then a man could be like
why does it always have to be from a
male perspective
uh because only males really deal with
that
the [ __ ] you mean specifically so
a few times today you hit on eggs your
eggs are dying
oh yeah you weren't hitting anything men
it's the same thing for men
genetically why no it's not the same
thing for men i think men could like
have kids well into their like 50s
oh my god oh my god i don't know how
kevin picks out these ladies and i don't
know why these ladies show up looking so
goofy
like you know what is he talking about
you know not the same thing a woman is
born with
a finite amount of eggs but a man can
also be
genetically deformed to where they can
[ __ ] what what are you talking about
you know oh my god
yeah which one would you say what does
she talk about am i the only one who's
watching this
and like look at her he'll tell she's
like
uh a man can also
imagine being like having that stupid of
an argument and looking so smug as you
stand there
what are you talking about is that okay
ma'am okay all right
due respect let's let's be that's not
the norm
sure it can happen but a woman
is yo see i made my point
men and women we do it then we don't
deal with the same thing
what do they call don't they call like
geriatric pregnancies on the
chair
uh
any pregnant woman over having a baby
over
35 is considered advanced maternal age
meaning her pregnancy is going to
consider high risk for complication
okay
okay so over 35 okay
male fertility generally starts to
reduce around age 40 to 45
when sperm quality decreases
all right so there you go anyways let's
just uh
i don't know why i clicked this video
our woman but it's the title
are modern women out of control i'm like
damn [ __ ] maybe i don't know i gotta
click this [ __ ]
he's born in utero with the same with a
set amount of eggs
i didn't make i didn't make uh
obstetrics
it's called geriatric pregnancy there
you go my man knows his terminology
let's go
you want to argue the science that's not
here
okay i'm just saying that's i mean
after 35 it becomes geriatric pregnancy
okay most women are not expected to are
not advised to have children past age
42.
is that the same for men
i don't know are you are you able to put
that statistic up there
oh my god this girl came to argue and
she don't even know the subject matter
if you're gonna debate somebody in like
bad faith
at least know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about drop some numbers drop
some stats drop some studies and links
man these goofy ladies just come and
find this man and he just puts them
and you know there's places where you
can't argue with kevin like he's not
necessarily right about everything but
the way that these ladies come at him
they just look stupid which just
reinforces his point like
she has no idea what she's talking about
she's a woman and she doesn't even know
the age at which she becomes less likely
to be pregnant
she doesn't know the differences between
men and women it's crazy i don't have
the ability to share a screen man but if
you're gonna ask the question
can men have children or produce
children healthily after 40.
do you know somebody that hasn't been
able to
who cares about anecdotal stuff say oh
my god
i know a lady down the street who had a
baby when she was 50.
so that's not the norm jesus christ oh
no man
the exception doesn't disprove the rule
you're asking a question and i ask you a
question you answer a question with a
question
okay so you have to make sure that
you're coming from both sides
no i don't what does that even mean
what do you mean both sides no i don't i
actually don't
i really don't care no no i don't
because i don't i don't i don't try to
come from both sides if you need
how old are you 25 25 okay
uh due respect young lady black women
have had
your views represented in the media in
the black culture but
most over my life how many times have
you heard black men views
what programs for every matter noir
essence ebony
uh grapevine the talk in daytime tv
where the where the male
into programs
where are they not
oh my god this girl where are they not
why don't you answer the question you
want to know why you can't answer it
uh because you can't think of those
shows because those shows they don't
exist
where are they name them i named like
sith i named 10 right there name
yourself
so you're saying that all of those
programs all those platforms do not
have any anybody advocating for the
black man i named 10 programs namely
so you're able to say that all those
programs i named 10 programs
maybe some i'm i'm saying those two no
no
you're asking you see yeah no oprah tv
all those stuff
that's not advocacy for black men
especially not from the black
perspective i'm sorry but those are
geared towards black women it's why the
viewership is predominantly black women
daytime television
is absolutely dominated by black by
women in general
but if you're going to talk about black
there's also going to be black women
because you know the men are
traditionally already out working so
they can't afford to be home
one two um those television shows the
width are set up is to
appear to black women we don't even have
late night tv shows
so yeah see that's the third every time
i ask you a question
no no no no i asked you a question
name these names name me three programs
that are from a male-centric male point
of view that are on popular daytime tv
or online okay name one that's not from
amazon no no
no no no no name one no name one
young lady young man
name oh my gosh she really said that
young mane name one she came to argue
she was not prepared
where's your dad
where's your dad tell him to come over
here so he can spank you because i can't
where's my dad he's at home i have my
own place okay
i'm 25 years old how old am i how old am
i i don't know
how do you think i am that's not my
responsibility that i
how are you when's your birthday i don't
know your biography well i'll tell you
what i'm trying to be respectful to you
but here's the problem i'm not being
hostile no no i didn't say you're being
you can say whatever you name me name me
any program that means three programs
that are on daytime tv
or that are on their own level of
essence ebony mata noir
grapevine anything oprah network naming
any programs that dominate the
are second oh okay all right this is
going to be awkward now from a man's
point of view
there is none exactly so don't tell me
about balance and being
being fair but that's not the woman's
fault
is it what is this girl talking about
someone told me to look this up all
right here we go
kevin samuels you know the one thing i
forgot to ask you when i was on your
platform is where's your wife
where is the woman that you are married
to that can prove
your thought process on what it takes to
have a successful black family
actually works because you have one
yourself
god damn is that just like the bra or
she got like triple oh
is this even appropriate god bless her
she
is blessed but uh let me play that back
i i didn't hear anything she said
as soon as i played this video she got a
black backdrop and all i noticed was her
black shirt
still that's how blessed she is kevin
samuels
you know the one thing i forgot to ask
you when i was on your platform is
where's your wife
where is the woman that you are married
to that can prove
your thought process on what it takes to
have a successful black family
actually works because you have one
yourself but then i realized you're not
even married
not only are you not married you have
been married twice divorced twice
she married
listen she married
all right i don't see a man i don't see
a man kanye west hey do my man kanye get
at her
hey my old khan you got at her god bless
her
i mean listen she's gorgeous
is that her
listen if a black woman is out here
posting videos of other people getting
married but you don't see a single photo
of her with a man she 100 percent
is single where's she black white don't
matter what it is if you go through an
instagram
and she got all kinds of pictures of
herself and she's celebrating other
people fall in love but she got no
pictures of her man she 150 in single
not that it really matters to me
personally but i do think it's kind of
funny that she's dragging him
for for being single or not married
and uh she's not married at all
but anyways it's not that important
listen uh you know what i'm gonna
save my commentary for after so
therefore
you mean to tell me you know all that it
takes
to have a successful marriage but it
didn't even work in your own life
interesting another question i felt to
ask is
where are your children are you a father
now i still don't know the answer to
this question so there's two
possibilities
a you could not be a father and then i
would be like okay marry twice no kids
that seems odd do you suffer from
erectile dysfunction
hmm
there's got to be a petty song there you
go let me play something like this
that [ __ ] was petty
listen whenever women do that that
always like rubs me the wrong way
the whole like uh oh you're not with
somebody is it because your penis
doesn't work like
why y'all say stuff like that i think
it's so petty but i don't know because
then again you could be a father
and then i would say you left the black
family unit
in order to pursue a youtube career
it was more important for you to have a
platform tearing down black women
instead of being married to the woman
who gave birth to your child
but i don't know if you're a father or
not but either way both of those options
seem a little fishy to me
and speaking of which you actually owe
every single black woman a thank you
card because you're
nothing without us
let me say that clearly kevin samuels
you are nothing without the black woman
because your popularity is based off of
tearing down black women
and it further proves the notion that
the black woman
is the least protected woman person
being on the planet earth because the
black man
even is taking joy and bringing her down
now yes there's a thing as constructive
criticism
and i black woman is the least protected
i've heard that so many times
the black woman is the least protected
woman
okay i will give you that and i was on
your platform
i even said there are certain things
that you have stated that i agree with
but what i realize is not coming from a
place with love
it's coming from a mean-spirited place
and that will not cause a change if
anything you are the
to the black man and black woman
relationship because you are dividing us
further apart
i have no
okay let me say if i grant her it's not
coming from a place of love who cares
who cares where somebody's coming from
when they're giving you advice
is the advice poignant and accurate and
real then fine
you know you saying it's not coming from
a place of love that's your subjective
opinion
me personally i don't really care where
it's coming from
as long as it's valid and it's accurate
and it's based in reality
who cares you could hate me okay you can
hate me
and if you got a real valid criticism
that's fine
who cares it's very difficult to come
from a terrible place
you know and to give person honest
advice
because generally if you're giving
someone honest criticism and honest
advice
it can't be from a bad place because you
would literally be going against your
own motivation
how does that make sense how does it
make sense for me to give you
information that can make you better
if i hate you i would try to be giving
you information that would make you
worse
you know what i'm saying like how does
that make sense somebody make it make
sense for me
you know what i'm saying like maybe
maybe maybe i just don't get it right
and maybe maybe i'm not paying enough
attention so i don't understand
but i just don't understand how you
could be getting
right like how do you get advice from
somebody who hates you
like valid advice
but uh maybe it's me but let me let me
just keep playing
let me just keep playing this
never seen more black men attack black
women
for issues of being a mother for being
overweight
or for not having a job or for not
being married by a certain age until you
came along and it's actually really sad
because black men
and black women we really need to work
together
you can't blame a single man for what
you're now seeing on social media or
seeing more of
you know like kevin is not jesus
okay he's not telling people stuff
he's not telling people stuff that they
don't already know he's just speaking to
or he's giving a voice to an opinion
that's always existed
you know kevin is not the reason why
single mothers traditionally have a
harder time in the dating life
that's been around well before kevin's
been on this youtube scene that's always
been the case
the only difference is you've never
heard it and you've never heard it
because there was no platforms where
people were talking about this kind of
stuff
at least not openly so it stands to
reason that
it's kind of confusing to me that you're
blaming him for the fact that people are
saying this stuff
when this stuff has always been true in
our society for a long time
you know the fact that you know uh
women more and more ending up and dying
by themselves
that's not kevin's fault that's just
true in reality
now that men are saying you don't die
alone that's not kevin's fault they're
just saying what they've already been
doing in action
right
you know the the funny thing about kevin
right and this is for me like
interesting it's like
me personally i was never into the red
pill community but i was always a fan of
patrice when i was growing up as a young
man okay
now patrice never called himself red
pill that's a bunch of other people who
called him that later
but he was saying a lot of the same
stuff that kevin's saying today and i
was listening to this stuff
maybe 15 12 years ago
right and so for her to blame him
this is nonsense it's really nonsense
you can't be mad at this man for saying
what a lot of dudes have already been
thinking or feeling like for a long time
it's putting the blame in the wrong
place uh and trying to scapegoat him
for something that a lot of dudes do
resonate with whether you agree with it
or not is irrelevant
but to blame him for it that's what's
stupid to me
we really need to function together
because that's when we excel
to our highest level and to the men who
do support
kevin samuels that are fathers to little
girls
uh here it comes here comes um do you
want your own daughters to follow his
teachings
do you want your daughters to be raised
to feel as though
the pressure to focus on just finding a
man that's willing to marry them
that she can have babies by and forget
all her other dreams because becoming a
housewife
is the most important goal that she
should have is that what you want
no no but what i do want for my daughter
is her to understand
what her choices and what consequences
that they are going to have in her life
you know whether it's my daughter or my
son if you just go in and you focus on
your career your entire life and you
neglect your family you didn't
collect your dating prospects i want my
daughter and my son to understand that
it's going to have repercussions
on your personal life you know
the problem isn't that women have these
choices and are exercising the choice to
do this or to do that the problem is
that they're exercising their choice
and then they're also wanting to have it
all and the reality is there's a cost
whether it be a man or a woman okay
there's a cost if you put 150 percent of
your life
into being a career woman right and you
spend all that time and you sacrifice
your
your dating opportunities and all that
stuff understand
you're paying a cost same thing goes for
dudes
right like being highly successful ceo
type lifestyle means you're going to be
absent in your kid's life
right for a lot of dudes that's the case
there's a cost to that there's a
strained relationship
yes what do you want me to tell you guys
like whether you're man or woman there
are choices
there are costs to the choices that you
make and the sacrifices
if you want to be a doctor for example
there's a cost to that it [ __ ] with
your social life
higher rates of suicide that's a real
cost
you want to be a soldier there's a cost
there's a cost as a man if you want to
be a soldier
there's a cost the likelihood of you
dying is exponentially higher
than you being a female there's a
societal cost
you're going to be away from your family
from a long time the opposite you being
divorced are extremely high
you know depending on what occupation
depending on whether or not you get a
job all these things
there's a cost so when you say
do i want my daughter to duh i want my
daughter
and my son to understand what are the
downsides of the choices that they're
going to make
what are they going to be giving up and
what are they going to be gaining
and i think what kevin's basically
saying is that for a lot of people who
become career women
they also have to understand that their
dating prospects don't improve because
of that
and that seems to be true with all the
stats that i've read up on
that doesn't mean that you shouldn't do
it that doesn't mean that you can't have
your career and also having healthy
daily life but also understand
there's a negative downside you think
it's easy to be a woman who climbs the
corporate ladder and spends all that
time
you know between your mid-25s to mid-35s
you sacrifice alive
you sacrifice a lot
so i don't know
i don't know i i just i just don't
understand
i don't know i don't understand some of
this stuff let me just pause i'm just
gonna read a couple of the super chats
kim dor hey chat appreciate it okay i
guess you made a cover song
hey man well thank you for the donation
man i appreciate it kenisha reese back
again kenisha
you you're just making it rain sarah
bangura
out here with a hundred dollar donation
put in some fuego some fire
in her donation let me let me just let
me just play that trick
thank you john pringle
with the five dollar thank you sir all
right let me just read a couple
more of these super chats cameron yola
thank you
crispy thanks again i saw a guy from
india got his wife pregnant at 94 after
being celibate his whole life yeah i
mean
possible without question thank you for
the donation shiro
k roxanne hey man i know we all suffer
an embarrassment right now levy below
i'd rather deal with
vr prawn than the chaos of argumentative
non-cooperative woman
damn julian harris i see why she's
single maybe she's not
ashton clark hey man just showing some
support you guys i like you guys both
have a balanced mindset
not left or not right thank you sir
theme is then thought
thank you for your will you react to
mine though i don't know bro i don't
know
i had a two tip mang as a 37 year old
blue collar worker from puerto rico i'm
a preacher the best positive street man
i've come across
thank you sir all right thank you sir
all right butch hold up do you guys
understand what i'm saying
do you guys understand what i'm saying
in this moment
right like about choices and how they
negatively impact you
okay i'm gonna you know what uh guys i'm
gonna just play a little bit more of the
track so you guys can hear it you know
what i'm saying because i think it's
always good to hear it
and i will be right back
[Music]
foreign
all right i'm back
okay oh my god oh my god stop stop
oh my god all right all right so anyways
um
i just wanted to get some water but
let's uh let's keep playing the video
your own daughters to focus on and
someone will say well kendra you're not
married so why should i listen to you
you know what i would give you that but
why listen to him
habibi don't you run a [ __ ] dating
show
like you're out here you know like
listen i think you could be married and
give great advice i think you could be
single and give date advice
i think you could be doing all kinds of
stuff you know
maybe you're unmarried because you're
widowed maybe you're unmarried because a
person
fell out of love with you and there's
nothing you could do that doesn't mean
that you don't have experience in that
realm or you can't give poignant advice
maybe you're single because you choose
to be not everyone wants to be like
this i'll be honest with you for about
eight years of my life
i didn't want to be oh my god
she out here replying is she what just
happened
okay absolutely likewise so that's very
nice to see civil
but yes uh so anyways you know
it's just a weird way to try to discount
someone's opinion especially if you
don't know the circumstances
if someone is helplessly single
that's different it's very different if
you have no
means to like get a girl to talk to and
you suck at it and you've never been
able
that's different than you saying listen
i know how to get girls
i know how to talk to them i know how to
get in relationships right now i'm just
going through a single face
oh you're single you don't know why okay
but anyways i digress if you want to
become a wife guess what
talk to wise talk to women who are
married
because they are doing the one thing you
would like to do
why talk to a 51 year old man who
doesn't have a wife for himself
who is still happily dating and to the
men who are single if you want to become
husbands you do the same talk to married
men
see look the problem with what she's
saying is
some people are not married because they
see what marriage looks like for some
people and they're like
i don't want what they got okay now
it stands to reason that there's some
validity to the argument like yo listen
if you want what somebody else got talk
to them about how they got it
but just because they were able to get
what they got doesn't mean that they can
help you get what you want to get
i know that sounds like a word salad i
know you guys are like what the [ __ ] you
talking about
you don't know how they got it right
maybe their parents are raised set up an
arranged marriage
maybe they just married their high
school sweetheart and they got lucky
maybe maybe
their best friend set them up maybe they
worked hard and they did get it the
right way who knows there's a plethora
of reasons but this idea that you're
going to talk to married folks and then
you're going to get
you know it's a mixture of both in my
opinion my my personal opinion
uh but me and percy do i have advice for
marriage hell no i don't know [ __ ] about
that so
if you want me to give you advice on how
to be a single [ __ ] you know i'm saying
and how to talk to you and get them to
be into you and then you know i'm saying
i can help you
and um generally my relationships have
been very positive overwhelmingly
okay so i just got a really cool dm i
just want to see if it's good news so
i'm going to just play it
but i'm gonna just turn off my mic for
two seconds
um
all right got some bad news didn't get
what we wanted but you know what you got
to just roll with the punches
um so we're going to keep it moving you
know what i mean sometimes you get some
bad news just got to keep them moving
can't stay
[ __ ] depressed and they can tell you
the truth about finding a wife and what
is really important
because at this moment it seems like
y'all made the modern day mister
from the color purple your king
god damn this is like such a terrible
way to handle this response
this terrible way to handle this
response but you know what everyone's
entitled to their opinion i like seeing
discourse like this
i just wish it was more poignant my
personal opinion but anyways i digress
you guys can hear oh you guys can't hear
yeah i didn't want you guys to hear
oh wait you guys can hear oh [ __ ] you
guys are here how did you guys hear it
hold up
one two three you shouldn't have been
able to hear
that was crazy if you guys heard that
that's crazy
um oh yeah
yeah uh real quick read off these donors
hey yo abba uh you're mean as hell joke
joke i love you i
appreciate you alana ora kirena bro
everything has a trade-off it must be
just a bias
yeah because apparently apparently he
did like a live with this woman and
and they went head to head honestly uh i
haven't really watched it i don't know
much about
these two um
apparently this is like the video in
question
we do this too often
acting as though women don't have
accountability and consequences and
immunity
no okay i'll let you go on for 30
seconds
and you say a man should be celebrated i
don't know why black women
come in and talk about men should be
celebrated you're supposed to celebrate
the man he's not supposed to celebrate
you
what what other race of women runs
around talking about them you need to
celebrate them
what are we celebrating who's on top who
leads
[Laughter]
oh my god should you celebrate your wife
i mean i don't think there's anything
wrong with celebrating each other
i'm not too much into this like oh my
god women are the best they're the
craziest my wife i'm so [ __ ] lucky to
have
it's just like man i love her you know
you awesome celebrate you and then you
know you celebrate me we got birthdays
celebrate me you know what i'm saying
but that's just me well kevin okay
who's on top who leaves um i i i do
say that yes the man leaves but i have
to just speak for the men that i know
that are happily married they celebrate
their wives
they do all right
hey man i want you to celebrate me you
know what i'm saying
i want to be celebrated i'm not even
going front i'm with kevin come on
please celebrate me ladies
i'm not i personally don't care as long
as you know there's
a good dinner you know dinner you know i
mean be like hey baby i'm glad you're
home here's the dinner for tonight so
let's celebrate you i'm like oh
let's go let's go
that's all i need me personally yeah i
mean
yo yo yo if i come home and there's some
ethiopian food on the table you know
what i'm saying
bless me
yeah celebrate each other i'm i'm down
the middle
i'm not gonna lie to you i know you guys
are climbing this woman how she looks i
think she looks fine that's me parsley
like
like oh hell yes
i don't know about that dress the dress
looks disgusting but
um her herself hell yeah
hell yeah
but yeah you probably you know my
opinion on this matter
but that's my type i understand it's not
for everyone for me i liked it
so that's me though you know shane yeah
yeah yeah yo anyways uh back to the
video
because i think we got a little bit off
track okay
so okay man but who okay
this notion is toxic
to come into this topic yes it is
because it keeps you it keeps women
with this over inflated stuff that they
need to be celebrated
to where asking women this i yesterday
had a woman
on instagram thinking that being a
traditional housewife was talking about
slavery just because she had to actually
cook a damn meal
i saw that so uh that's a woman
that's crazy slavery someone really said
that
i think sometimes women see the whole
idea of like a house my for being
submissive is like
going back into time or somehow that's
something lesser thing
i agree with the idea of like yo you
know for so long we've kind of demonized
like the traditional form of a housewife
that we should probably encourage and
see the positives in
in the opposite end you know me
personally i i don't like that aspect of
it as like
if a woman chooses to stay at home that
is somehow like a terrible choice
like now if you don't want to do it
that's fine
but i don't know why you would call it
slavery that's a weird one it shares
your reflection
how she's black oh she's my reflection
you know and that's one of those things
where i think people really like um
people really miss the importance of
these things i'm going to just speak for
myself so it's completely anecdotal
but i think one of the the aspects of
relationships that i love the most
is like just coming home to my partner
we're just chilling and it's it might be
quiet but you know i mean
maybe my head's on her lap and we just
chill in the living room
and you know it just feels nice and
relaxing just to have
someone's proximity you know
and i think just how soothing that is
and how how good that is and
when we talk about like the idea of like
man i want someone who's passionate
career oriented just me personally like
that stuff is not the
most important thing for me it's just
like when i have this person in my home
does my home feel better
you know and um you know when i think of
the idea of
even me like sometimes you know i'll
just make
you know she's still sleeping i'll make
her breakfast right
and i see how like excited she is in the
morning when she gets seasoned like
everything's cool right
and there's nothing nice about creating
that environment for somebody else
that's like the moments that i really
enjoy
so when people think that the idea of
doing that for someone you love is
somehow slavery to me is like so sad you
know
that's just me personally though i'm a
simple person
maybe i'm basic but that's the [ __ ] i
love the most about relationships
not the that's me
yes so my notes the notion the way
and you know like a housewife people
making sense of like having a good
home bro is one of the most important
things in life it's like the reason why
i moved out when i was 17 because
home wasn't home for me it was terrible
so to have somebody who can make
and amplify and make my home better and
make you know when you have a roommate
you don't get along with it's like one
of the most
miserable things having somebody in your
home that not only you like get along
with but makes it
tremendously better it's not a small
thing it's one of the greatest things
that you could have with somebody else
in my opinion
but that's just me
so many women talk as though you're some
like you're some sort of god or deity
that's supposed to be celebrated
the way we do it over here is
men of value lead women of women of
value
follow them you celebrate your man you
praise your man
what y'all do on your side is good for
you hope it works for you but more
people on this side are winning
more people on that side got opinions
and no husbands
especially no husbands they value so you
talk about russell wilson i don't know
many men
on this side that respect russell wilson
not because he married a woman with a
child it's because he's a symptom
why is that why because
that's an entire program and here's the
thing how about this
because the men say he is
i mean that's not an argument but hey
i've always thought kev you know okay
you know what
maybe i'm being unfair you know why when
that man was talking about i'm gonna
wait till marriage to bang for the first
time being the nfl athlete that he was
that's a religious value and i and i
can't knock him for that so you know
what i'm gonna take it back
i'm not gonna call him a simple he just
has different values
if you value chastity in a woman right
and you say virginia is good and all
that stuff how are you gonna look at a
man who wants to engage in that same
behavior and then call him a sinful
and that's generally why people have
done it he got with ciara
sierra or whatever ciara um
and he and he maintained his virginity
and he just sounded so like docile
you know maybe that's also another
reason why they called him a simple yo
chad
why is he simp russell
wilson why is russell whistling simp
what five reasons why russell wilson is
the worst kind of soup
okay hold on watch this video oh my god
jay de black i i've never watched this
guy's content let's go
here what's my biggest fear
not be prepared yeah i probably have one
that's bigger than that
was it l-o-s-i-n
[Music]
losing her oh my god
okay that's just corny
one two
being this much of us
i take back what i said i think i think
they might be on to something that was
that was [ __ ]
corny now enough with a sentimental
stuff
what is going on everyone i am jada
black
shout out to he's afraid of losing her
made peace with their situation
all right i don't want to watch youtube
videos so i'm going to just go this
five reasons why russell's the worst
kind of sucker ass simp ass sucker
is this going to be satire i think
there's got to be satire this is the
root
there's no way there's no way this is
for real
okay all right i [ __ ] how did i know
that this was gonna be satire i'm a i'm
a genius i knew it
there's no way they had this kind of
title on the root
listen bro his name might be damian
young but he might as well have a purple
vagina because i'm telling you
this is the most feminist uh [ __ ]
left-leaning black
website ever they they write crazy
articles like
why emojis are racist this is that place
okay there's no way this
knows no [ __ ] way
how did i tell you bro how did i tell
you
there's no way they would write this
okay
one he's dating someone new and is
actually bringing up our name in
interviews and taking her to events with
him like he's actually happy to be with
her
who the hell does that besides a sucker
as simpass
suck oh my god ah this is so cringy you
know what
if the root is defending russell wilson
he must be a simple i take it back
i'm sorry guys i apologize i must be
wrong
[ __ ] okay yeah let let me see me
okay let me see this [ __ ]
somebody's got a short video please god
okay this man's he's in his he's in his
truck
you know what let me let me listen to
this guy
reaper we keep it rough
hey hey man imagine if you wake up and
this nigga's just hovering over you
we keep it rough we keep it rock man you
already know that butthole's about to be
gaping
pause we keep it real
make sure you subscribe to the reaper
hey bro i kind of want to subscribe just
so i don't die i'm gonna give it a like
i don't know about
because we're doing good things here at
reaper
he keeps saying a reaper but i think the
way he says it sounds like rapier
would keep doing good things at rapier
oh my god oh my god
why is he talking like that can anybody
tell me why he's talking like that
oh my god hey we doing good things at
rapier
all right let me just click play all
right the reaper gonna make this short
and sweet russell wilson
is simple the year
russell wilson went on the talk show
and said his biggest fear
was losing his woman sierra
not him getting paralyzed
no not him getting raped by me
losing sierra well that was a mistake
russell
cause i'm coming from that booty i want
you
and i'm gonna have you chris hanson
all of his money not someone dying
his woman let's analyze this for a
minute
you know because the reaper just want to
know
stop stop calling yourself the [ __ ]
reaper bro yo i don't know who this man
is but go subscribe that [ __ ] is so
crazy
i'm a no bro you know what i'm
subscribing the reaper
deserves a subscription hey man
no bro
okay all right there you go okay back to
the content bro
that's just crazy bro
no bro stop bro
that's just crazy let me just click play
on that
okay oh you guys know about booty
warrior you guys
you guys know what i like you and i want
you
and i'm gonna have you chris hanson
they call you chris hansen but i call
you chris hanson
[Music]
let's go is simping
the new thing and is simps
giving women a false sense of reality
that this is going to this is what real
men
you know should be like hey man this man
could give a
morgan freeman a run for his money this
man's voice is crazy bro
if you heard this [ __ ] in the dark bro
run i don't care if this man's offering
you flowers candy
a light cigarettes a million dollars
[ __ ] just run
you know it's a sad situation
you know to see a woman paralyze a man
you know by willingness
to please her you know the reaper keep
it 1000
you know
the reaper give him 5 000
and some men you know their willingness
to please
a woman it paralyzes them
and russell's been in different
relationships before
you know um he was married once in
different relationships and it didn't
work out
that woman you know cheated on him
allegedly with golden tate
his wide receiver and this is why golden
tate
got traded to detroit can we just take a
second appreciate the name
golden taint
imagine imagine your girl cheating on
you with a man called
golden taint which is apparently his
real name
but it sounds like a great name for a
jojo character golden paint
that sounds like a golden shower mixed
with a rim job bro
that's crazy let me see russell
wilson's ex-girlfriend
um
okay so he was with a white girl before
let me see let me see who she is man she
got instagram
is that her there's no way that's still
her there's no way that's her
i refuse to believe that's her is that
her
i'm not even gonna fret though that's a
huge upgrade i mean he might got a
cheater on but
[ __ ] that's an upgrade bro damn
damn good for russell man i mean he
might have been a sip because you know
whatever reason he got cheated on golden
taint and whatever all that stuff but
i mean [ __ ]
yes sir oh why does he look like lionel
richie on the right what the [ __ ]
happened
russell wilson got a girl who like
clear upgrade and then he decided to be
like hello
is it me you're looking for like that
was unnecessary he didn't have to do
that whole portion
but god damn that is an upgrade and a
half
bro if i'm going to get cheated on i
also want my next girlfriend to be ten
times better looking
stop playing with me bro
you know what i mean like
yo listen bro you know what oh my god
look at her looking all ethiopian with
that hair
yo what is sierra's background sierra
heritage
sierra look a little foreign
why do i care oh no she's had a lot of
hair so i was just wondering
moving on let's go back to
my man over here the reaper because
he was sleeping with russell wilson's
wife
now we know you know why
russell wilson's last wife
you know um wait who just said that is
not an
upgrade sean graham huh that's not an
upgrade [ __ ] what
is it because she's white no it's not
because she's white bro it's because she
wasn't good looking
now what are are you serious bro
you don't think sierra is not an upgrade
stop playing bro
hold up hold up stop playing with me you
don't think
she's an upgrade okay this is her
this is her bro okay all right you know
looking like her her lips are about to
disappear
all right let me even say her name right
sirara sirara
okay oh hell no
oh hell no stop playing with me
you know i mean you could say whatever
you want about sierra but she good
looking
stop playing stop
playing sierra looking is ten times
better look it's not even a contest
y'all are bugging y'all are bugging
what what is this what is this
what oh hell no
bro this girl thinks she she kind of
cute because she painted on [ __ ] lips
stop playing with me bro you kiss her
you go straight to teeth
no protection no front door no bouncer
there's nothing here just
nah bro you think what
compared to listen i'm only saying this
because she cheated on my boy russell
wilson with golden taint or else i would
never be
this critical of people's looks but
come on bro hey yeah sean graham i
looked at the wrong girl you damn
[ __ ] right you did
stop playing with me y'all out here
bugging but anyways let's go back to
russell wilson being a simple
was cheating on him because russell is a
simp
and i think sierra is just waiting her
turn
you know she's got her a square nfl guy
who makes a lot of money because you
know what
i am going to defend russell wilson here
you know
maybe their relationship is going to
work from what i understand in sierra
used to be with future that really
wasn't working out it was a toxic
maybe now that she's in a relationship
or she's being cherished and she's
having a dude simp for her like
she likes the other side of that coin
better you know being with a dude who
neglects you and doesn't give a [ __ ]
about you
right maybe that's gonna make you feel
some type of way
you know what i mean so
i could see the opposite like if i had
to choose between being neglected
and having someone cheat on me
constantly versus someone being super
loyal
and always at my beck and call i
probably choose this me personally
so i could understand her maybe sticking
it out this idea that she's gonna leave
him because he's being super simpy
i don't think it's necessarily gonna be
true but who knows
all right so this is the video
let me ask you this let me just before i
go let me ask you what what is your
response when people ask you
what was the prayer what do you think
because that's all people want to know
you'll be acting like you don't hear
people asking you the damn question
what was the prayer that's what they
meant
because i pray with you many nights i'm
like telling you
the point is what you just said that i
prayed many nights
i think i think that's the biggest thing
is like
people always say the prayer it's not
just one prayer it's multiple prayers
like
especially you know when you're going
through a big transition in life like
for me as we
you know all know i was single mom in it
that was something i never
envisioned never imagined and i think at
that point when you're in a time like
that in your life you have to think
about like
exactly where you are and where you want
to go and so
yeah because i remember you always
telling me like you have to envision it
speak it believe it all right there's
gonna be a lot of that like religious
mumbo jumbo stuff that they do
the steve harvey you have not cause you
ask
not write it down
you don't have it cause you didn't write
it down you gotta visualize to
materialize
it sounds good because it rhymes
if you stay patient with the rhymes
you will get what you want in due time
if you'd like a wife seek a life full of
strife
you want someone who's wife material
but are you husband material
i can't stand this [ __ ]
you asked for it but did you pray
for it see god will give you what you
need
not necessarily what you want
you want to get married
but are you hairy
see i know what i'm talking about i know
how to keep a wife
because i got divorced three times
you gotta visualize to materialize
you want a girl who cooks but do you
read books
do you read the book look
hey have you done the prayer
yes well girl he won't be a slayer
he'll be a simp not a pimp
call him russell wilson
he will give you many sons
will son will it
son because he wields it son
all right all right if you are watching
the program have you donated to the
program which is programming your mind
see this knowledge isn't free but it
will
set you free
from a cloud to a tree
now if you love yourself and you wish to
materialize the good things in your life
i will be accepting donations for the
next
five minutes as i heed
all your prayers give me your blessings
as i have already blessed you i have
paid it forward now pay me back
because you don't want to be that friend
who've taken money hanging out of the
cookout
a year later like you don't owe me
nothing hmm
while you're over there grabbing your
collard greens
should i need to grab you by your green
collar
and ask you where my money nicka
all right let's see those donations
let's see those donations you guys want
to be up in here just taking my advice
uh fema says i think celebrating black
women is about uplifting the image on a
macro scale thank you sir
i appreciate that celebrate your black
sisters eliza reyes says can you react
to kevin samuel's video about how
being a housewife is like slavery i'll
watch it i'll watch it later
watch mr unlimited hello he's corny will
do reaper just keeping it real now
open your p cassie amos thank you for
the dono
siporraga says sierra only got with him
because she got tired of making
bangers with every rapper she went out
with
i'm not gonna fret though you know the
goody song that was fire so you know put
some respect on sierra's name
all right shiro preach bring abba back
to reality thank you for the donor
william hall now get the reaper on here
to read these rhymes hey man
yo put some respect on the reaper's name
that's my that's my dude
that's my dude that's my dude
all right all right let me just keep
going a little bit here okay
oh oh my god i see you guys being stingy
you guys are out here being bingy
watching my content
and that is why there is no content
within your lives
you guys are trying to fill a void
that i've tried to help you through okay
you want to find love well show me the
love show me the money
or else you'll never find yourself a
honey
do you want to be the honey that
attracts the bear or can you bear to be
alone
i'm just giving you bear advice
so you could get with bare women
the bad women from all right let's just
keep going jaden hill jones should i
learn crayola you should always expand
the knowledge of your mind
giving you better rhymes better times
better lines
better signs of what's to come with the
future
futurama
clearly the theme to this church of abba
is katakuri theme for one piece
no all right let's keep playing you know
you know
i mean i guess the uh five before
the five we were gonna go write down
what those were i had to have a clear
vision
what that was and so for my five
non-negotiables
the first one is i wanted a woman of
faith that's the number one thing i
wanted i wanted
that was important to her i wanted a
woman out of faith
the second thing is i wanted one who was
faithful third thing i wanted is
ultimately i want an independent woman i
wanted a woman of faith i wanted a woman
who's faithful
full of faith and as
face as faith filled her i wanted to
fill her with some other stuff
some other brush to paint within her
the love that i wish to see inside her
and i want to see inside my kids
see i'm faithful to god i nod
to the almighty
amen i wanted a person that
didn't have to be sierra they could be
doing whatever but they had their own
identity had their own
perspective on what they wanted to do in
life and
and how they wanted to impact people and
that was something that i noticed from c
the first time we met and
how she spoke about others the fourth
thing was i wanted a woman who was gonna
love me
the way that my mom loved my dad when he
was on his deathbed you know and
and how she my mom took care of my dad
no matter what the circumstances were no
matter how hard it got
you know our family you know be honest
we went bankrupt at one point and
just it was hard it was heavy it was
heavy times and you have to be able to
um you know my dad always knew that we
were going to be good
you know that we were going to be giving
my my my brother myself and my sister
that we were going to be okay
because my mom was helping lead the way
honestly i don't know nothing about this
is like driving me nuts i i don't know
why people call them a sim to balance
with you
maybe i missed it but you know it seems
very healthy they seem happy so
i'm not even gonna clown them personally
but anyways i digress
let's go back to this well okay as a
female that i want to sing
because if there's a man well then go
ahead then you so so so you want to have
a
so again and thank you guys listen to
what she said and she wants to step
she wants to self she wants to see him
because a man
a man like russell wilson who puts
sierra on a pedestal
pedestalizing a woman is i said this
three weeks ago
show me a culture a race of competitive
people
where the women were pedestalized above
the being show me a competitive
civilization you don't
men's purpose needs to be pedestalized
not the female
does that mean that the one see there's
a problem so many women in the black
community
want to be sitting up like this queen
and if a man is sitting up here looking
at you
he cannot fight everybody else compete
with everybody else and defend the world
sorry doesn't work that way and that's
why so many women black women are by
themselves because they
if they can't be treated like the queens
that they think they are
then they'd rather have nothing and no
one's going to stop
okay this is what i'll say i think
generally speaking this is not entirely
inaccurate i think generally
women do want a man who can lead and you
know will you know be in the forefront
and all that good stuff
but i do think that for some folks the
opposite end works well i don't think
it's necessarily the model for society
personally um but you know if it's
working for those two
on a micro scale i have no problem with
it i just wouldn't glorify that as how
every relationship needs to be
me personally uh nor is that what i want
for my relationship
um but i digress i i
i don't think that russell wilson's like
some kind of indication of a
of a of a terrible trend but maybe i'm
wrong
it ain't because the problem ain't black
men it ain't black men because ain't no
man marrying you
when it says one out of four black women
were married that means anybody
so your career your job your
accomplishments whatever is walking
around making you feel great and
wonderful about yourself
that works well until you about 55 or
60. then what what's about the rest of
life
um are you asking me that direct
question
the point the ultimate point is we get
nowhere when we have women
who still think they should be
celebrated ahead of the men
well i think they should celebrate each
other and we what maybe we
should be celebrating who should be who
should lead
i don't i don't mind the man being the
head of the house
i think you can lead and also celebrate
each other equally maybe they're just i
feel like they're arguing semantics
i feel like they're arguing semantics
personally i don't i don't think this
one's really that good
all right so what was this slavery this
is the one that you guys wanted me to
watch
so which one which one do you guys want
me to watch
is it a slavery one that being a
housewife is like slavery
get this old pan out of here all right
all right we're gonna have to watch
we don't have to watch another one all
right i'm gonna wrap it up with this
video because uh
we decided we were not gonna cover this
but uh
okay so this is the one right
i actually don't know what i don't i
don't know what happened with this story
so i'm gonna swatch it big story out of
dc
a carjacking that left a delivery driver
there
dead but now two teenage girls ages
15 and 13 have been charged with
assaulting him with a stun gun
leading to the crash that killed him a
lot of questions being asked now
including
if services like uber eats need to do
more to protect
drivers our ariel reshef joins us now
with the very latest good morning ariel
good morning to you t.j that deadly
attack on a 66 year old uber eats driver
happened
in broad daylight 4 30 p.m as he was
trying to deliver food
those two teen suspects arrested in a
shocking
and senseless crime this morning
two teenage girls oh this is toronto
looks like toronto girls arrested
charged with felony murder
and armed carjacking after police say
they violently attacked and killed an
uber
of course this is washington each driver
in washington d.c
oh yeah i know my police cars
i've been in enough cities for long
enough to know what they look like the
suspects
just 13 and 15 years old were in the
process of trying to steal 66 year old
mohammed anwar's car
when one of them used a taser on him as
they tried to speed off
which police say led to the deadly car
crash
the car flipping over anwar ejected
he was rushed to the hospital with
life-threatening injuries
but did not survive okay
okay
i'm going to ask you chad i'm going to
ask you guys a very poignant question
that i think is important for this
discussion
okay and i want you guys to be honest
chat
do you think that these children are
these two right the the 13 the 14 year
old
do you think they're old enough to
assume the responsibility
of the weight of their actions
that they have the cognitive ability to
be like they understand what they're
doing
and they should be charged this if you
think that they can put a one in the
chat if you think that they can't
be responsible put a two in the chat
and i want to see your answers put a one
if you do think that they
they can't be responsible
and um accountable for their actions in
this which is town amount to murder and
carjacking
so put a one in the chat if you think
they can be
okay
okay all right okay
okay so so so so this is what i need to
understand chat
this is what i need to understand you
guys are gonna have to help me out okay
because it seems like
overwhelmingly the answer is one okay
overwhelmingly the answer
is one
okay
now
if you feel like these young people were
old enough to understand the weight of
their action
and kill somebody and they have to
assume the responsibility of that
okay okay
no reduced sentence put him to jail
whatever charge with manslaughter
is it that 14 and 13 year olds can
understand the gravity and take the
decision to kill somebody
but you don't think that a 17 or 16 year
old can choose to consent to sex
now i want to say this i'm not
advocating that these young teenagers be
out there banking
i'm not advocating none of that what i'm
trying to understand and this is what
always confuses me
is that we're gonna try 13 year olds as
adults
and i'm fine with either answer i
personally don't care too much
we're going to try 13 year olds as
adults or 14 year olds and 15 year olds
as adults and say go to jail for life or
get charged with manslaughter
which i'm fine with so we're like yes
you know what you know what you're doing
you can assume the responsibility of
[ __ ] murder
or killing people people have the
cognitive ability to do that
but they can't choose at 16 or 17 if
they want to bang the 20 year old
i just um and and i want to say this
very clearly
this is not saying that they should bang
this is not saying that they shouldn't
be charged
my problem and what i will not
understand for the life of me
okay is how we charge young people
as adults saying you knew what you were
doing when you murdered this person when
you robbed them or whatever
but you don't have the faculties to be
able to decide who you want to bang with
how is it a false comparison how is it a
false comparison
this is my point and you can't refute
what i'm saying because there's
literally
no counter-argument there's no
counter-argument this whole age of
consent this all like they're old enough
to drive
it doesn't make any sense we constantly
change
no no you you guys can't you how you
can't justify this other than your own
emotional response and like your weird
relationship with sex
and again i don't know how many times i
have to say this i'm not saying that
young people should be out there bang
that's not the point
my whole point is we treat young people
like adults at random points and then at
other points we truly don't
and you're not
so okay okay i want you to read this
response okay guys i want you to read
this response
taking someone's life is different than
getting your rocks off apple
i would agree i would agree
i would also agree that killing somebody
right engaging in manslaughter
spur of the moment decision
okay a young person probably has less
ability
to handle that than they would a sexual
encounter so
if we agree that one is far more serious
far bigger of a decision i.e
manslaughter
okay how are you gonna sit there
and say they are perfectly capable of
taking somebody's life and knowing what
they did
and understanding the repercussion of
such a serious action
but when it comes to sex they can't
oh we should let them drive at 16. we
should let them join the military at 17.
we should let them only [ __ ] at 18. we
should only let them drive at 21.
we shouldn't let them drink at 21. pause
this is what i don't understand i don't
even understand what are the criteria
for charging someone as an adult
okay
guys understand get your emotions out of
it i'm arguing
purely from a logical standpoint the
basis on which we desu
decide to charge someone as an adult is
what i have an issue with
okay that's what i have an issue with
because nobody can give you a logical
answer
nobody can we should charge a 14 year
old as an adult
why because they should pay
for what reason you've just argued that
they're not mature enough to understand
the weight of their decisions that we
don't give them that responsibility
but we should give him the consequences
of a full-fledged adult
what why the truth is a lot of people
just want to see folks pay
because something unjust and [ __ ]
tragic happened right
something absolutely terrible
absolutely terrible happened and we want
somebody to pay
and we want them to pay and to suffer
because somebody else is suffering
but that's a completely different thing
than
whether or not these young folks
understand the weight of their actions
i'm sorry gonna be honest with you guys
i'm not saying that they shouldn't be
punished punish them do whatever you
want i personally
i don't have that much weight but i will
not delight
that the way that the public engages in
this discord
there's zero logic behind it it's all
emotional and
arbitrary there's no consistency
right and you guys can get in the chat
and get as mad as you want
but the truth is there's no consistency
there's no consistency
here's here's an argument
there is a difference manslaughter is
black and white it's wrong
see dwayne this is why you didn't think
about what you said manslaughter
literally means
that you were just dangerously negligent
manslaughter is not black and white
it is the definition of chaos chaos that
a
you were extremely negligent in what
you're doing you think young teenagers
understand the concepts of deep neglect
really
what are you talking about
when you're chock full of hormones and
peer pressure and all kinds of
stupid ideas you think that
young teenagers every day young
teenagers will get on their bike
and ride down the wrong side of the road
like idiots they'll make all kinds of
stupid decisions that put their life at
risk
every single day and you think they have
the mental faculty to understand
manslaughter
what you think that they have the
foresight to imagine how their actions
could end up terribly
you think that when those kids try to
rob that car that they thought that they
really could have killed that person
that they were prepared for such a thing
you really believe that
you're treating them like adults but the
truth is that they're not
they're not adults they're not adults
and i'm also gonna say this and i'm
gonna just be frank
okay the u.s justice system
is really just punitive for the sake of
it they love to see people pay but
there's no logic behind any of the
sentencing
you know we charge teenagers with
manslaughter over fist fights that they
get into
i remember one time there was a case of
like a 15 year old that got into a fist
fight all right
and he knocked the dude so hard on the
head during the fight the dude hit his
head and he died
they charged him with manslaughter as an
adult
they charged him for manslaughter for a
teenage fight
one-on-one manslaughter
maybe that makes sense to you guys maybe
it does i don't know
i just don't understand the logic of
like charging young people as adults
like are they adults are they not
yeah and people can say they
respectfully don't agree they don't
think what i'm saying it's right or blah
blah blah but
there is no logical argument for the
arbitrariness of charging people's
adults
for the arbitrariness of the age of
consent for the arbitrariness
of all these ages at which we decide
people are ready to do certain things
you can you can't drink until you're 21
does that make sense
of course it doesn't it doesn't make
sense nobody can justify that stupid law
i could take out a 50 000 own but i
can't drink tom 21
what that's stupid that's stupid
it's stupid i could be charged as an
adult when i'm 15
even though i'm clearly not an adult but
i don't have the privileges of being an
adult
what does that mean what does that mean
what does that mean when you say you can
charge people as adults
so as long as we all admit that it's
super arbitrary
and that none of this makes sense i'm
fine with it let's just keep going
but don't sit here and act like
don't act indignant when people disagree
with you
on something that is so subjective
okay
it just doesn't make sense that's my
opinion
that's my opinion i think something
tragic happened there was a loss of life
two young people did something [ __ ]
stupid but
you know
okay so this is another reply he says
they tased him stole his car crashed it
and killed him
their actions overruled their ability to
comprehend
their actions overrule their ability to
comprehend no idea what that means
laws against youth having sex area
because they don't trust the adult
in the relationship that's not true
that's not true
that isn't true at all that isn't true
at all
because they actually also charge the
teen with the crime
they also charge the teen with the crime
yes
if you're a teen and you send pictures
of yourself to people they're gonna
charge you as well
none of these laws make sense none of
these laws make sense
and i just think it's kind of crazy that
we have a judicial system that's so
you know arbitrary nature with some of
these costs that's my opinion
see someone says age of consent is for
the adults not the kids that's a lie
it's also for the kids
because guess what if you're a 16 year
old and you bang a 15 year old they can
also charge you
that's right yes if you want to send
pictures of yourself to somebody else
who's 15 they're also going to charge
you
they're going to charge a 15 year old
i don't care i don't i don't want to be
involved in this realm this is not
something that like
keeps you up and i'm like whatever i
just look at it and i just cringe when i
look at it
and if you guys think it makes sense to
charge teenagers as adults
i think you live in a very [ __ ] up uh
system
personally i just don't understand
how you can say that these people don't
have the ability to
drive they don't have the ability to you
know take out loans they don't have the
ability and any of the rights and any of
the responsibilities of adults
but you think you should punish them as
adults i don't understand that
you know that's me personally i'm never
going to understand it
and people are going to be hyper
emotional in the chat and be like oh
you guys are just like trying to ignore
the fact that a murder happens that's
not what i'm saying
but we also have to be a little bit
logical about this
one can acknowledge both things right
one can acknowledge both things
one can acknowledge that one something
tragic happened and something very
terrible happened to this person two
that the people who did this should be
held responsible
and three that trying them as adults
sounds stupid
but hey that's me
if you're not going to give them the the
privileges
of being an adult i just don't
understand how you charge them as adults
and i don't like the fact that it's
arbitrary because generally
when these laws are arbitrary you know
who gets most [ __ ] by it
poor people
so those are my thoughts on the matter
you guys wanted to know and so i
answered
but yeah yeah generally i find when i
have these conversations especially with
americans and they talk about crime i
just cringe uncontrollably
americans think that they understand
like
how a judicial system should work but
like your levels of crime are
unbelievably high your incarceration
rate is crazy high
most of your laws don't make sense and
just encourage criminality so i'm like
bro i don't look towards the american
model justice system for what i think
justice should look like that's me
personally
like y'all been failing at it y'all been
failing at it
so why would i why would i listen you
guys you guys
i'm being honest this is just by the
numbers you guys are doing terrible when
it comes to crime
and and prisons you're doing terrible
okay and and every time like a crime
happens
everyone gets excited send them to
[ __ ] jail kill them whatever right
but you guys are not doing a good job
you're not doing a good job
and it's okay to have your own opinion
and keep it as you want
but
you're not doing a good job how is it
that your prisons are
overflowing with people
you know we talk about you know this is
nothing that bothers me talk about this
stuff right we talk about like uh
you have to set an example you guys have
been trying to set examples you have
some of the stiffest penalties for some
of these crimes
known to man right and people still
commit the crimes at astronomical rates
so what does that mean does that mean
that americans were born on this country
in the soil
or have like a gene that predisposes
them towards committing higher levels of
crime
or just maybe some aspects of the
justice system are just broken
you know listen i love the states i love
going down there
i love the people in a lot of ways but
some aspects of your system are trash
and it's okay to say that you can love
your country
love being there i think i love going to
america me personally i love going to
the states
i know a lot of people hate on it and
they're like i would never visit
me personally i love visiting but jesus
christ your
your medical system and your [ __ ]
your prison system you like your
judicial system absolute trash in my
opinion that's just me
uh i'll be right back just give me two
seconds just give me two
seconds guys
[Music]
oh
foreign
all right i'm back i'm back i'm back you
know and guys like when i say this stuff
it's not to be like um
it's not to be like oh my god let's just
have a free fall let's encourage anarchy
it's to just
let's think about the way that we've
been doing things you know
let's think about the way that we're
doing things
when i was living in los angeles bro bro
the way that they policed the
communities was just garbage
and the relationship between cops and
the and and
the neighborhood i lived in bro like the
poor ass you know how you want to know
how i knew i was living in a shitty
neighborhood [ __ ] i used to walk
outside of my apartment complex and see
chickens on the lawn bro
it was like the poorest mexican
neighborhood i'd ever seen in my life
loved
the people around me they were great i
remember i used to hear cucuracha
trucks you ever heard those it's those
[ __ ] mexican trucks that roll through
and they hit the horn and then they have
that little
shitty ass horn but anyways
and when i lived there bro for two years
man i'm not gonna front you
um i'm not confront you man
like the relationship that i saw between
the locals and the cops was really like
it was untenable it was untenable
and but i remember how many times
bro he's crazy man i can't tell you how
many times i was just like riding a
bicycle like up and down
like some some neighborhoods bro and
cops just rolling up on me i saw like
the it was different
it was different and um
and i always think that's like such a
giant failure specifically for los
angeles obviously
but even when i went to different parts
of america like i just noticed that the
relationship between
law enforcement especially in major
cities
and um and the citizens is terrible
this is really bad but i'm also not
surprised because i see how the cops
react
that i see other people react i'm like
damn i'm not surprised i don't get along
whatsoever
someone said la sucks i mean i agree
undoubtedly
you know you know what this is what i'll
say about los angeles
if you're not from there it's terrible
and if you're from there
if you're fortunate enough to ingratiate
in like the local neighborhood and not
the [ __ ]
transplants who live there it's a lot
better
in my opinion like when you're in los
angeles and you're just around the
tourists or the people who are not from
there
it sounds terrible it's actually the
worst experience in my opinion
but once you get out of that it's
actually a lot better
what else um i don't want to spend too
much time on this
the teens arrested at the scene anwar's
loved ones calling the sudden loss
immeasurable telling abc news the father
of three and grandfather of four moved
to the u.s from pakistan in 2014
to build a better life for himself and
his family
it's more than tragic i don't even know
that word describes what happened is
senseless
police say they've seen a spike in
carjackings in washington d.c
and in several other major cities since
the pandemic began
in 2020 345 carjackings were reported in
the nation's capital
more than double the year before the
city launching a task force just last
month to help
focus on these incidents because it's
very important
that we find out the people who are
responsible for
for these carjackings and that
that we have justice uber drivers
nationwide have been on alert after a
string of attacks
earlier this month a san francisco uber
driver was assaulted and taunted by
belligerent passengers
authorities arresting one of the
passengers and charging another with
attempted robbery and assault
uber now teaming up with law enforcement
who are available to work with police 24
hours a day to respond to urgent calls
the company telling abc news we are
devastated by this tragic news and our
hearts go out to muhammad's family
during this difficult time
and uber says that it is grateful the
suspects were arrested police not
releasing their identities because they
are juveniles both teens have pleaded
not involved which is the adult
equivalent of not guilty
tj it's ariel russia for us thank you so
much
well these are protecting their identity
all right so
hmm
you know whenever i watch videos like
this and the p2p will talk about spike
and crime it's always interesting to me
how
spikes in crime especially north america
always seem to coincide
with when poverty seems to rise
anybody knows that [ __ ] people are like
man i can't believe how much crime is
risen
between a pandemic how many people have
lost their jobs
like i don't think people recognize the
link between poverty and crime
oh wow i was gonna pull up studies for
you guys but i actually don't want to
make the stream about that
all this to stay um you know
when you see stuff like that happen it's
always tragic and i always feel bad
but i always wonder if people are really
putting their hearts in the right place
in regards to like finding solutions to
these issues
law enforcement's great but you know you
know what's better than law enforcement
we need law enforcement don't go crazy
like oh my god i was talking about
[ __ ]
defund the police that's not what i'm
saying but what i am saying is like if
you fix a lot of these economical issues
right if you fix
the problems that we have in regards to
job loss and all this stuff
poverty like just dissipates so fast
it's even the same stuff with a lot of
like racial issues i'm not saying racial
issues
will be 100 solved uh as poverty is
reduced
but there is undoubtedly truth to the
fact that as you go
higher up in income problems like you
know a lot of those issues also
start to dissipate so yeah
anyways i'm gonna wrap it up with one
last person to react to and then we're
done for today
okay so uh
here we go this is the last person who
reacted
let me see oh yeah this girl
apparently she reacted to my comment
hey there you go
there you go there you go there you go
how you doing sister
dude i mean we out here stream streaming
this [ __ ]
but anyways i digress um i'm going to
take one
suggestion from y'all on a last video to
watch
and then we're going to wrap up the
stream because we've been going on for a
long time
abba i would love to go on dinner and
date with you down to earth good vibes
i'm a terrible vibe i'm
absolutely man if you get me on a date
bro
you don't want to have me on a date
i just come in they're all awkward like
oh do you like video games and dungeons
and dragons
please make love to me
all right here we go this is gonna be
last video but when lockup visited
kentucky state penitentiary
we met felice johnson a long time inmate
who practices a very different kind of
homosexuality
but we have sexual desires right so you
got a bunch of mans locked up
in one place all of them get hard
all of them's haunted all of them got
sexual desires so what are they going to
do
if you won't let them have a woman
they're going to have each other
somebody's going to have to give us some
booty
the most uh memorable story
that fleece told us was about
the place and importance that
food has in a maximum city why is this
guy talking like he just came out of
stamford just got his degree
for [ __ ] media science
guys like the importance of booty
in prisons that story was absolutely
riveting
and he went on about it and on about it
in his prison
booty booty was uh
more important than food booty a man's
butt
booty a man's butt just in case you
didn't understand booty
like the [ __ ] gluteus maximus a man's
butt
got it i'm coming for that booty
it was more booty you see how he's
laughing
the reason why he's laughing is because
the guy behind the camera is trying to
not laugh
because he's got this deadpan face look
at that face booty
you know what this needs
it was more booty having some booty
was more important than drinking water
you know what i like the most about this
light this line he knows it's [ __ ]
but he's doing it for the television
but he's trying not to laugh if a [ __ ]
said something like hey man
i'm definitely going to return your car
if he's lip if he has to adjust that
[ __ ] that nigga's lying
what's more important than drinking
water
if they go it's more important than
drinking water man
they adjusting their lips so it doesn't
look like they're gonna burst out
laughing look at this face
[Laughter]
[Music]
this man is holding himself back
he's holding himself back trying not to
laugh
booty
[Music]
especially during the 1970s and 80s when
he was most active
and prison security was more lacks
when i see one
and he looks good to me when i go see
him i say
you coming as i'm telling you what
uh i like you and i want you
and um we can do it the easy way out of
the hallway
the hard way what you gonna do
and it was always yes johnson also had a
warning for the new generation of
inmates
they might be asking for trouble from
old timers you know they got this thing
where they saved their parents past a
book
it's a style they call it some sort of
gangster style
you know it's sexy to us right and
see but they were prepared for this
right so you said your friends and her
man somebody be up in your butt
you know and it just said so johnson
even let the lock-up crew know
that when he was in his prime they
wouldn't be safe from his advances
either
if y'all hadn't been in heard back then
in them days and
as much as i liked booty i've probably
felt one of y'all but
hey y'all was walking past password
and there is you just say i'm not no
shame in my game this is nothing that
i'm ashamed to admit
i am what i am
when a new jack come in prison like he
don't have no imagination what's going
on in prison he don't understand
who's who what's what right most all
young guys come in prison
they will try to find a homosexual first
to find out who got the drugs who to
talk to who not to talk to
you know which best way to move on right
in certain jails you have a lieutenant
standing up there and when guys come in
everybody's standing up there they're
pointing down yeah that young
motherfucker's mine that's mine
i talk to a lot of them because i'm on
the reception side right
and i see the fear in them so i know
right
i can give them to a shark or a bad
cooler
if i sell a guy believe me i'm gonna get
something out to do
first of all right if he's a newcomer
right i want him to suck my ass with
jello
what they call toss the salad that's the
sling where he tosses salad
it means sucking my ass right with jelly
or without jelly some people use syrup
i prefer a guy to use jelly right i
would reach my climate
right i would automatically get hard
right i will you know
come automatically if he's sucking my
ass for about 10 minutes or longer right
it's it's a it's a sensation film it
makes you feel real
good most all gays do that you know i'm
saying like guys the stuff they have
it's just like a [ __ ] right but the
only difference is it's not a [ __ ]
right it's clean the person's decent and
the person know that that's an [ __ ]
but in mine he
be looking at it as a [ __ ] because
hey man this is crazy
this shit's crazy anyways man
i think i gotta wrap it up there because
that [ __ ] was i wonder what happened to
fleece johnson
did he ever get out do you ever get
released
oh man i wonder if i get an interview
with this man yo
chad if you guys can find fleece johnson
on instagram or something yo haul at me
bro
but anyways that's it for today's stream
hope you guys enjoyed it we'll be back
with another video a little bit later
deuces